we are also brought to you by the best
supplements on the planet i'm talking
about on it on it.com
fighter you need alpha brain you need
new mood you need total gut health you
need freaking protein powder
joint oil krill oil earth grown
nutrients you need to mix in some
protein powder to get your soil ass
ready you need creatine to look all
bulky sun what you need you need mct oil
check
you need elk bars check you need coffee
how about [ __ ] yeah coffee how about
black rifle and onyx collab
they got cree caffeine crystals
i was gonna say creatine crystals they
don't have those thank god they have
caffeine crystals in their coffee
it's the strongest coffee you've ever
had your boy likes a deep dark roast and
[ __ ] yeah
coffee from on it and black rifle get it
done save 10 off the best coffee on the
planet
on it.com fighter for 10 off you need
fitness gear we got you
kettlebells uh you got freaking
on-demand training yuck club maces you
got sand
bell sand bags battle ropes whatever you
need on it.com
fighter 10 off get you some right now on
it.com
fighter 10 off all right
uh josh wolfe thank you for answering
the call
you got it i saw the bad signal go up
the bat signal was up
yeah it was up and you answered the call
so we love you man the fans love you
here
obviously we gotta address this just off
the top uh
you know you guys you guys have seen the
the brian callum news my partner in
crime
brian the kid callum my brother from
another mother
i can't get too detailed into what
everything is going on
if you want more info brian cowan posted
on his instagram
his rebuttal his defense to exactly all
the allegations that are going on with
him
so i'm like callum speak for himself
um callum has asked me not to go
hard in the paint for him on the show
and uh because
apparently if i say what i want to say
it's going to count in more trouble and
bring more attention to callum
so my my hands are a little tied which
is very tough for me
very very tough for me uh because i
think you guys know how much i love
brian
and uh obviously i stick by uh brian
callan
and uh some of you are like uh
why isn't brian doing the show you know
and all this stuff and this was brian's
decision
this was brian's decision uh in best
interest
of fighting the kid and uh you know the
corona stuff and getting his lids done
he's just you know i've never seen him
like this brian's exhausted yeah brian's
exhausted mentally and he's held by his
lids
you can't tell he looks fresher he looks
happy and surprised
with the lids but let me tell you that's
that's hollywood's best
that did his eyes yeah yeah so uh
you know brian's gonna take some time
off and i support him i said i'll hold
down the fort
um and that's what we're doing and we're
gonna have
uh you know a uh a reoccurring co-host
and
we'd love to have you as much as you
want and we'll have some other i know
people you guys love
so you know for doing the show for seven
years and
um every every week i've never missed a
week man this this is my baby no matter
what i have else going on
i could always rely on finding the kid
and brian and even when brian you know
was busy shooting tv shows or hollywood
movies that
we still did the show you know and
you've been in a number of times and a
number of other people
have filled in for brian the kid
calendar so um by no means
or we can stop doing the show and um you
know
i just i hope brian figures it out and i
think he will and
um in due time brian will be back and
i'll tell you this
i spoke with brian right before we did
the show and you know that video that he
posted
you know he's he's reading the comments
i told him don't read anything on social
media
he's never listened to me he's never
gonna listen to me but he decided to
read all the comments
and uh the amount of support that brian
has received overwhelming
overwhelming for everybody rallying
behind him man it means a lot to him
uh these fans know brian callan and uh
you know again it's hard for me not to
to to release the hounds and give you my
true thoughts
and uh i don't think it helps him though
it does it and
and that's the only reason why i don't
yeah trust me i i would love to
uh you guys know me man i've gotten in
trouble i've lost jobs over it
uh from shooting from the hip and saying
what's on my mind and
unfortunately you know people much
smarter than me who've dealt with this
situation before
say don't do that brendy if we can
actually one thing if you can do the
show
don't do that yeah so i'm not doing that
even though it's against everything that
um
that that i know yeah but it's just it's
the smart move because ultimately
well i can't say anything that's gonna
satisfy that's the thing anyone who
wants me to give
you my hot tip right right so anything i
say it's only going to hurt brian
that's the last thing i want to do and
so you know
i know you called me and you were like
hey we need somebody about his age but
way better looking and i was like well
i still got the right guy i said you're
the only guy with a better body
and a better set of hair at his his age
yeah without a doubt can you you're
a bigger better looking version of brian
the kid calling yeah i mean i
also you know what else i do like he's
been doing the show seven years i do
like that you address him by first and
last name like nobody knows who the [ __ ]
you never know some people like wait who
they think you're him
like wait he's sitting here no he's not
you keep calling him brian cowan i'm
like
if you call them brian or callum i'm
sure the people who are listening to the
show
know who the [ __ ] you're talking i'm
just i'm trying to be very clear right
now you know
everyone's walking walking down his
nickname in there brian the kid can't
brian the kid counts
one two two nine seven e
yeah you know the guy i'm talking about
five eight getting him up at bryant
like what the [ __ ] is he doing dude yeah
no i got it
it's just uh it's a weird time man you
know in
anyone with opinion that's fine and
everyone should have their opinions
but at what day and age are we guilty by
social media
if you give me proof you give me proof
yeah of anyone i'm with you man
here's the thing here's the thing also
the problem is
why everybody's skeptical about
everything and by the way i'm with you
on brian
a hundred percent i'm behind him 100 but
i obviously can't say anything either
because
what can you the problem with wait real
quick also this happened and
the the major allegation happened in
1999 yeah
21 years ago yeah i was a sophomore in
high school
i wasn't there i don't know what i could
add to it i have no idea
like brian was like oh i'm going to do a
emergency podcast
you you know i was like yeah i'll come
in dude and and all and he's like and
you
and this is brian goes and you're gonna
do what i go
i'm gonna be like your flavor flake and
he goes but you have no idea what
happened i go
i know but i know what you told me goes
yeah but dude it's 21 years ago
like if i do that podcast you're going
to sit there and nod your head you're
going to look
stupid let me handle this yeah this
isn't your fight this is my thing i'm
not going to drag you into this
so i was like all right dude i was
willing i was out of town i was like
yeah i'm gonna drive down and do things
like no you're not
he was you don't you you were he was how
old were you i was a sophomore he was
dude we didn't even know each other and
sophomore in high school you were still
jerking off in a sock
oh yeah you know what i mean yeah you
were still sucking into it and i know
what i was jacking off to
to really yeah it's a cd album cover
called and it's a mixed black girl
on a hood of old school like cadillac
with her ass cheeks out
now that i look back at it what wasn't
working with a lot but it was wait but
but
but you were no it's not a little rider
magazine it was a cover it was
album her name was called mercedes type
mercedes rapper
rapper female rapper let me tell you how
old i am it's a it's a
why are you jerking off the coolio bruh
wait i love the name of this album rear
end
oh dude and i would jack it hard
okay we have something in common not
that i was jerking off to this
but what i was jerking off to when i was
a sophomore in high school
she was also on the hood of a car her
name was tony katane
it was the white snake music video here
i go again
that is what we were now i'm aging
myself a little bit because you're like
a white snake
but here i go again oh my that song
that great song oh dude today it holds
up the music video
tawny kate
but she was a big actress too right i
think this is what
sprung her into whatever she ended up
doing
but she was just so sexy
what would you say is there ever has
there have you has ever been anything
you jerked off to and you felt bad
after that you dropped off oh yeah uh oh
yeah
i mean so you're like what's wrong well
someone what's wrong well sometimes when
i pull up like
my pornhub or porn you you porn look at
that she's ridiculous by the way
yeah sometimes when i pull it up and
it's like suggestions i'm like
why oh what in what world yeah
what algorithm did you see i'd be into
this but you're like i'm like i mean
i'll give it a try
all right but you know how when you're
like raring to go like it's like yeah
it's kind of hot
then when you get done you're like dude
you're disgusting
like german goo girls yeah i've talked
about this before
dude and then i get done like these poor
girls
i i i have there's one thing that i will
say that i googled out of curiosity that
i didn't jerk off
to but it's the only thing that i've
regretted and i like
weird things brendan i like really weird
[ __ ]
if you're like who's the guy who has the
worst videos on his phone to show people
oh it's me that's it you and you my
catherine i got to tell mike
dude quit texting this stuff i sent the
guys at bar stool
a video kfc yeah i sent kfc a video
jared over there oh and and and his
buddy who he does the pod with
threw up while watching it like kfc will
tell you i send them i can't i can't
deal with any of that
i sent i saw and i don't like violent
ones like i don't need to see your legs
like snap oh you've seen those videos
with people's legs snapping
while having sex no no no
oh oh i was like wait there's a door
yeah
they're like snap legs they're in dude
you've never seen
an armbar while he's nutting i showed
you last time i was here i showed you
larry the cable guy
snapping that dude's arm with the
armrest that was fantastic this
episode of the fighter and the wuff is
brought to you by
a little thing called the zebra it's
been reported that americans are
overpaying on car insurance by over 21
billion dollars you kidding me
but searching for a better deal can take
hours typically results
uh in a barrage of unwanted spam calls
until now thanks to
the zebra.com the zebra.com is the
nation's leading car insurance
cons comparison site because it's the
only place you can compare quotes side
by side from over
100 providers choose the best for you in
90 seconds or less
plus they will never sell your
information to spammers so you won't get
all those unwanted annoying calls
you just answer a few quick questions uh
it's simple
it's a fast form they find you the best
rates and coverage in your state and
booyah you're ready to go
techcrunch calls the zebra the kayak for
auto insurance the best part is
it's completely free it's free y'all you
can save up to 670
a year using the zebra.com
the zebra is committed to making sure
you're covered at the lowest price
possible how much can you save on car
and home insurance and home
go today and start saving at the
zebra.com
fighter that's the zebra.com
fighter t-h-e-z-e-b-r-a
dot com slash fighter the zebra dot com
slash fighter
listen while calan's gone man one thing
he's doing is getting his grill fixed
that's what i'm hoping he's doing he's
taking time out of his day
he's stressed out and he's faking his
grill all right
that's what he's doing he's using candid
candy clear aligners they're comfortable
they're removable
totally invisible so it doesn't look
like you're wearing wire braces like a
dork
don't do that there's candid your
treatment is prescribed and monitored
remotely by a licensed orthodontist
who's an
expert in tooth movement candid only
works with orthodontist never general
dentist like other companies now we're
talking about the real
mccoy real orthodontist with canada you
can treat your treatment includes
remote monitoring by the same
orthodontist who created your plan
so you have to wonder how you're doing
you'll always know exactly what you're
doing
and we love that average candid
treatment is just six months
what you start seeing results way before
then and the cost
uh is less damn damn near 50 less than
invisalign
all right so if you got a messed up
grill you're ready to uh take the first
step toward getting your dream smile
you got to get started right now uh from
the comfort of your own home with
candids risk-free starter kit and 75
off go to candidco.com fighter use the
code
fighter that's candyco.com
fighter code fighter for your risk-free
starter kit and 75
off to the perfect grill candyco.com
fighter code fighter yeah sometimes it's
like can you watch
can you watch like the like the cartel
videos and like the beheadings of like
ices and stuff i don't like that that
will ruin my day like there's this
documentary called
the last narc and it's about this uh dea
agent that was working with the mexican
cartels like he was an american
who was sent down there to stop the
mexican cartels in the 80s
and they kidnapped them and they torch
them for over 36 hours
and this documentary goes into his wife
and the the four guys who were
in the room and actually kidnapped him
and apprehended him and they talk about
the torture that they did don't
i couldn't sleep last night my girl
couldn't either it was one
and she's like i can't sleep no i don't
like that stuff oh dude it's like
so just to fill you in uh it's last it's
called last narc it's on amazon you guys
know me in my uh documentaries by the
way
documentary is for me that's all i watch
yeah i love it's like you know you learn
something
it's great so um
this is it's it's so dark and it's just
like
what they would do just to fill you guys
in a little bit and this is this
happened in [ __ ] 85 so
spoilers suck it so um what they would
do is they kidnapped him
and they would torture him so bad he
would he'd get unconscious
they had a doctor there they'd give him
a drone to revive them they keep
torturing them
36 hours dude 36 hours but these
how much torch do you think you got in
you how many hours do you think you get
into you before you're like [ __ ] it
how after what for you i wouldn't be as
polite as he was
like they have the transcript of them
yeah interrogate him and he would go
please stop hurting me like his whole
thing would be not screaming he keeps
saying sir
please stop hurting me please stop
hurting me it's like i would not be like
please i'd like you
piece of [ __ ] yeah because you know it's
over it's like i just want you to never
forget now kill me fast that's yeah i'm
gonna talk so much [ __ ] yeah you're
gonna want to kill me yeah
that would be my i wouldn't want to just
endure all that i would talk
so much [ __ ] insult everyone start
roasting everyone like
just [ __ ] this guy's so annoying i'm
with you 100 i when i look at things
that people endure
like my wife and i have been watching
this show called alone do you know what
that show is oh yeah where they're alone
out in nature
they're their own camera people i would
be two
a day two days max i like like i know
there are people who watch it like i
could [ __ ]
i could do that when i watch that my
first thing is
honestly because i enjoy showers how
where do you wash your [ __ ] well
there's that lake right there right so
you just splash the water up
yeah but it gets so cold man like where
do you wash your [ __ ] how bad do you
smell your clothes alone would be a
complete nightmare i'd last
one day and i was a boy scout so take it
easy but
the other thing is you can tell that
your boy scout by the way you hit that
you're a scarf
yeah yeah yeah i know and i'm rocking it
every day now are you it it was just for
precautionary rona times and now i'm
just like this [ __ ] is swaggy man i
think
he's like a [ __ ] boy like cowboy you
really do yeah i did just like
take it easy you ever tucked it into
your shirt never but i will now
um i think you should tuck it in like an
at this dude here man
this [ __ ] some people are
savages on there
so he is obsessed with the show i am
obsessed this guy here okay
he had 30 he looks like this like he's
leaving auschwitz
he had 30 pieces of fish he was just
like i can eat
one piece of fish every other day
because he was planning on staying
through christmas so he was just
rationing yeah because it used to be 30
days or 60 and then now is it just like
whoever lasts as long yeah you well
here's the deal
it's whoever lasts the longest this last
last season was if you can do a hundred
days in the arctic
they'll give you a million dollars it's
a milk because i know at first
it was like 60 days and you got 100
grand it's like get the [ __ ] out dude
here's the deal
the early shows are more people like me
and you i mean they have more skills
than you and i
got like pros who and people who are
like i've been living alone for 30 years
you're like yeah
of course you have and then you see them
out there and then some guys
flourish yes like i i got really into
naked afraid when i first started i was
balls deep naked and afraid
i was talking about in every show me and
callum did like uh
a fake naked afraid on fire kid 3d and
they saw that and then they
they they sent us the email like hey
what's your guys interest actually do
naked
naked and afraid i'm like oh i love that
show me and count could you be so much
fun
i was like what's the pay oh there's no
there's no pay
no your pay is just the experience yeah
get the [ __ ] out of my face dude
you know i for discovery i did their
live
after show so i met all those people i
ate a live cockroach on tv
four naked and afraid i ate brains oh no
not friends
um what else did i you've done a bunch
of naked afraid you did shark weekend i
did all that stuff i love
live man you know why i love live so i
did naked afraid i did naked in new york
where you know the worst part about
being naked in new york was not being
naked was being barefoot
i was like am i oh you know what you
that was i don't mind you
patient zero for corona yeah barefoot
new york
cut off my [ __ ] feet but we were
naked so i'm walking down the street and
there's a woman with her phone
literally this far away from me pointing
it and i go what are you doing she goes
oh i'm taking pictures your dick
oh wow dude it was hilarious without
when i was in san fran i think first
time ever did cobbs
out there it was me and brian we're
walking down the street with our friend
tara kazeem and joseph
and there's just a dude with a briefcase
but naked with a [ __ ] ring on and not
like
not well endowed i was like bubba what
are you doing
pick a different [ __ ] yeah yeah like
it's so distracting highlight a
different body here's the thing of san
francisco
no one batted a [ __ ] eye to it they
didn't care at all it's what i like by
the way you can find the video of me and
michelle you know who michelle beedle is
oh yeah so michelle show michelle and i
ate the live cockroach on my show
okay is she still part of nba stuff no
she's not she's taking a little time off
she's she's the she's great michelle
beadle you know what the the sheep
podcast
she hop on pi she can't hop on podcasts
right now she'll have
a contract but she does podcast and
she's
amazing i was gonna say if i was gonna
invest in anyone to start a podcast
if i had my own network i should kind of
do i would invest in her and somebody
else i'm telling you right now she is
russian so heart smart girl we did naked
after dark
[ __ ] okay so we this is when they
were like so we're eating a live
cockroach because that's what they ate
absolutely
but i will tell you afterwards they ate
it uh on the on the show hold up so part
of the big guy was on naked and afraid
part of my deal
that thick beer no no not the guy
standing up
the the guy in the bowling shirt at the
end who looks like the next grateful
dead fan
no he's the guy who owned the cockroach
oh gotcha that makes sense so with live
cockroach
and beetle i have to tell you the
options of the things that i could eat
the other things in the jar i picked
cockroach because cockroach was the best
option when michelle ate this
she almost threw up live right i would
go watch her right here
[Applause]
and they're gonna re-eat it we we just
and by the way this is
this is when i was oh i've seen that guy
this was the creative wreck ears
oh she makes me want to look at you
doing the damn thing
you were okay with it dude nah okay is
the wrong word dude
you're a good actor here's what it was
here's what it was this is the horror
performer in me
this is the absolute because i got
stabbed on live tv
for shark after dark this is the [ __ ] a
guy from walking dead
why so this guy actor from walking dead
yes
stabbed you on not on accident no on
purpose you guys were in a fight
so this guy on shark after dark came up
and he was like uh
hey i have a shark proof i have a shark
proof
suit the bite proof like the chains yes
and i was like oh and you go and he
showed us video of it right
of him putting his arm in a tiger
shark's mouth and it getting
no so what he told me after which he
didn't tell me before
was and i would have been nice if he had
told me was yeah man like
the shark's teeth didn't go through but
my arm's never been the same because it
ripped
oh yeah it ripped it out of the socket
and i jiggled it around
right so i say to the guy i go hey let's
do
let's put the chainmail on i go ken he
goes you know i've never actually tested
the suit with knives before
and i go what he goes well it might work
it might not but it should
i go can we test it during rehearsal and
he goes no let's not do that i said why
not
and he said because if it doesn't work
during rehearsal you're not going to do
it on tv
oh interesting and so smart i said yeah
but man i could get stabbed on live tv
and the director who was watching and
listening to us the voice of god just
came over the speaker and he goes
that's good tv yeah i was like that's
right that's where my head goes yeah
good tv same thing with the live
cockroach man so where did you put the
chain on to get stabbed
so he did it on his hand the guy whose
thing it was
did it on his hand his hand got broken
i did it right he i so i go i'm going to
put the chainmail on
your heart i go stab me here and the
director was like well we need you on
this side so he has to stab you on the
other side i go that's where my heart is
and the director goes just don't hit his
heart and my friend was like i don't
know where his [ __ ] heart is oh wow
so is a guy named michael cudlitz he
stabbed me so hard
that the knife bent it didn't puncture
that why did he stab you that hard
because i kept telling him hit me get me
harder oh
he did it a little and did a little
nothing because i was like nothing when
he stabbed me hard
it tore my muscle but it didn't break
the suit
so it kind of did its job but also
did not did it hurt like a [ __ ]
or was your adrenaline going oh it hurt
afterwards i've never torn i've never
had something go
into a muscle like that before do you
know what i mean but i will tell you
dude i
love live tv i love
doing things on live tv that make people
uncomfortable do you feel like yourself
on live tv like
yeah we've thought about doing live
fighting the kid but then you look at
the analytics of like youtube and stuff
it's
it's a nightmare yeah the reason why
rogan stopped doing it right so
on live it's just like i'm an idiot dude
i say some you know some yeah you know
just some [ __ ] i probably shouldn't say
and if it's live like you know i've done
the pre and post shows for the academy
awards the oscars for e
and you know it's it's live and i'm like
well i better watch my p's and q's yeah
but i know me where it's a liability
you're dealing with live bullets for
lack of a better pun there but it's like
you know when
i forget his name like little ooze or
something showed up you know the natural
comic in me starts roasting him because
he looks ridiculous i start roasting
like god talk about a downer
you know you're like dude dude
you're not you're not on your podcast
that guy came on here as a guest
look at the way he's dressed like you
have to [ __ ]
why are you dressed like that or lady
gaga walks by with this huge
like entourage and they're holding her
thing and you know we're on live tv i'm
just like
god you know just you just it's what we
do like
to me like i want to make everybody that
laughs so it's just
they're walking my roast and then the
producer's like hey just maybe sit this
next round out dude like
no one's enjoying this the viewers
they're upset it's like all right sorry
dude
sorry man did he say the viewers
oh dude yeah yeah they didn't have me
back
they didn't have me back yeah and you're
not thinking about the viewers they're
not
they don't want it it's like oh look at
that elegant gown and look at her
looking so pretty
and i'm like yeah that must suck look at
all you know i'm just like
i listen i would do you got to remember
who you hired a comic
to do something serious you know the
when the one of the reasons that i
didn't do shark
in the following years is because they
wanted to make it more serious and they
asked me they said hey do you want to
come back but we're going to make it
more scientific and i was like well then
you should hire somebody who knows
something about sharks
yeah but i'm just kind of cool and let
me let me just go like
i like if you toss me a video let me run
with you man yeah yeah do my thing and
i'll stay within this boundary but it's
i'm going to mess with it
dude you've meant to gilder paul yes
that's so that's why i met paul oh well
and i've known paul for a bunch of years
okay so we had tara read on
tara reed by herself made my show go
viral
the interview i had with her where she
thought
whale sharks were when whales and sharks
oh hell yeah [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh yeah so god bless her let me
tell you she was dead stairs she was
that serious [ __ ] yeah
you go there's the clip you can see
there are two parts of this clip
where she's going off and i look
yeah i look straight into the camera
because the director is telling me
this is probably just another the
director is telling me hey hey go
she's losing it go to commercial go to
commercial and i look right into the
camera and go like this
no letters on tv man if you're gonna cut
me off you're gonna have to cut me off
but i i kept looking because the
director was like she's she's losing it
yeah that's what we want dude dude so de
gelder was on this like a comic bomb
oh man this is what i'm here for the
best this is what i'm here for you mean
it's not another
stuck-up interview like no let her go
this is it
so the gelder was on the same episode
after the episode you know he's got a
fake hand but he was wearing a black
glove
so she walks up to him and she said uh
um
why do you wear that glove on your hand
fantastic and um everyone's like oh no
and so paul is a really good you know
he's a he's got a great sense of humor
he'll laugh about it
he goes uh you know i but he was just
being straightforward i got you know
i lost my hand i got bit by a shark and
she goes why'd you do that
oh no oh
no yeah dude and i was just like i wish
this was on tv
but she so this is what she said he goes
launching some utterly incoherent
rambling on sharks so this is searches
so i looked up sharks on here this is
great i looked up sharks on there i see
whale sharks i'm like
must mean a whale shark and a shark
heads or whale and a shark had sex and i
think
well how does a whale and shark have sex
because whales are mammals sharks are
animals
they're both animals yeah they have
nothing to do they have nothing to do
with each other
uh joshua didn't bother to hold back
their smirks
so basically they're followed by sheer
mercury mockery
so basically the dolphins have sex with
each other but the sharks don't so i
thought
then how is it such a thing but the
difference is the whale shark is the
biggest shark in the ocean
he's also scary and you have the great
white who's also scary
there are over 400 kinds of sharks with
the whale shark it's kind of interesting
because he's so mean
he's like a killer but like not really
yeah
yeah they just eat plankton and if you
run into a shark that's the one to run
into
yeah that's as you don't get swallowed
holes just stay away from its mouth
because it will open its mouth this says
we're not even going to bother
explaining everything that's wrong with
what we said
the video is so amazing because ayan
had just been doing his sharknado tour
with her so he had a look on his face
like
i can't believe this is where i am
you know what i mean because and he's
like i'm sure he heard that so great
though
he was just like but and me on the other
end that's candy for me i was just like
what the [ __ ] i love it i would keep
feeding her all sorts of
sh before the show she had two
glasses of wine with two pills right
next to the
and so i was going over and she would
take a pill and drink the whole life
she's so hollywood by the way
dude i i don't know like i was like i i
think i have no idea what pill that is
but two pills and two full glasses of
wine means this is going to be a great
amount of fun
this is going to be on that show weird
you kind of know
like if it's going to be a good
interview and it's also
this isn't necessarily a show but i'll
give brian a look we've been a long
enough or i'll give them a look where
i'm like dude
this ain't going well yeah this thing
get to current events bubba
like this is not going well or even you
know what whether it's food truck diary
or something like that like you just
know you're like ah and
i'm just like ah [ __ ] you can feel an
energy oh you're just like oh this isn't
going well yeah and they know it's not
going well and you're just like oh god
but it's one of the reasons honestly
that i love live
because people have a little forgiveness
when they know you're just weighing in
it
and they almost like to see the train
wreck especially if you acknowledge the
train
yeah it's weird when they just pass over
the train right like
have you have you seen that lady she's
interviewing
the commissioner of the nba and he has a
huge nose i mean it's just what it is
he's like this yeah and she goes she she
can't help she you know
like they're getting ready to start you
know and she's sitting there and you
tell she's just staring at his nose and
she's probably going
don't say nose don't say nose don't
comment on his nose
and she goes there's something you know
like she says something about his no
off the bat about his giant nose and you
just see her like
don't think we've ever seen her again
you know that's the moly moly mold
that's it right there telling her head's
like don't say no's don't say no's
right off the bat dude it's like as a
comic
you know when i listen to like young
comics if i see a young comic who's
an enormous person and they don't get on
stage and at least acknowledge that
they're an enormous
alphabet or if you're if you have a
something about you that sticks out if
you're very flamboyant
you have to acknowledge what everybody's
thinking
to be able to move to be if you
if you don't you can never move past it
because that's
cut the tension for everybody yeah like
my like right when i started uh doing
swatch around la
you know obviously i don't look like
your dish traditional comic i'd go
i'd get up there i know i look like i
should be teaching your crossfit
crossfit class or some [ __ ] like that
that's not what this you know i've this
whole rant about how i'm in shape comics
i mean look i mean if i've never seen
jeremy piven do his stand-up
but if i'm him my first 10 or 15 minutes
is about being jeremy pivot
it just to get it out of the way yeah
you know
because you like you know well look at
louis ck yeah if you've seen louis
louis ck like it's like obviously
there's a huge elephant in the room
about him jacking off and all that stuff
and he goes
boom off the bat boom has two well the
great ones do the great ones know what's
up
you know well you have to you obviously
the people there are your fans
especially for louisiana they all know
what's going on they know what's going
on so you can't
they want to hear your take on it i know
you just ha
you have to you know and so like
yeah i i i feel like that's live tv for
me
we had a guy come on so one of the
things
i was like i want to know i think it was
for shark after dark i want to know
how how like how intense a shark bite is
like what does it compare to
so this dude built basically jaws that
he could turn it so i had a different
pressure
and that i forget what they say a shark
bite the pressure is right so it was
going to go from
cat all the way up to whatever the top
one he keeps cranking it up too it broke
on cat
but the segment was five minutes long
dude so we gotta
so hey hey buddy listen i know you're i
know your thing broke on cat but
we got four minutes and 58 seconds
what'd you do well i we [ __ ] about i
was like this is
the worst segment we've ever had in the
show it's great
yeah i mean he tried to fix it and he
did it he was like no no i think i gotta
fit and at one point the top jaw just
[ __ ] fell
dude the best the most awkward live
situation was kanye west
with i think it was um uh mike meyer
when when he uh he go you know they're
like doing some like
it was on snl yeah was it no it wasn't
snow it's live tv they're doing some
like
charity thing it's live tv oh yeah
yeah he starts going off about bush and
all this stuff yeah you see mike myers
like uh
yeah uh uh and kenny's just on being
kanye
you're hanging over raising money hard
in the paint yeah
but by the way i think i think oh was it
obama i figured maybe it's bill clinton
he don't care about black
people yeah and all that and then you
see mike myers like oh my god
i don't want to be here you just like
tell he sees that that's the face right
there
that's it right there george bush don't
care about black people look out he's
like
he's like [ __ ] i'm shrek bro i'm shrek
[ __ ] i'm a canadian man get the [ __ ]
out of here
now i'm on tv yeah what are you like
america's hurricane relief
yeah dude the audience will be able to
hear the audio yeah protecting new
orleans the landscape of the city it's
all dead serious
and perhaps irreversibly there's now
over
kanye just right ready streets you had
this ready to go for
days i hate the way
they betray us in the media if you see a
black family leah mike
they're looting see a white family he's
over
looking for food oh no it's been five
days
because most of the people are black and
even for no mike's all scrap take this
tv because it's too hot look at mike
he's like what the [ __ ] did i sign up
for boys
like is this an snl nobody told you that
kanye west is crazy
and and just to imagine if i would look
at his face like
this is not i know he's looking off
so is that some awesome powers three not
going to happen now or
uh the poor man you know mike myers
right now he's like
like when i was like i want to die am i
not in canada right now yeah he's like
why
how the [ __ ] how are you talking about
this is the stupid i couldn't i couldn't
have done this on remote
i'm nodding my head fighting another way
and they
they've given them permission to go down
and shoot he took a step to the right to
try to get off camera
and subtle but in even many ways more
profoundly devastating is the lasting
damage to the survivor's will to rebuild
and remain in looking kind of like yeah
i didn't create enough drama i got one
more thing i got to say hold on let me
drop this he interrupts him
george bush doesn't care about black
people
[Applause]
look at chris tucker look at the suckers
[Applause]
chris tucker look at him right there
he's like man i thought i was in trouble
for wearing stripes on camera
chris had the earpiece on and he was
president
and chris turner's yeah
you know when they cut away he was like
what the [ __ ] man i bet he was just like
that was good stuff dude got back to the
dressing room i was like what the [ __ ]
oh my god i will tell you one thing by
the way
that if you there's nothing better
if you told me tomorrow there's going to
be a new austin powers movie
i'd go first day i i love all three are
fantastic the one with beyonce was a
little weird but
dude they're good gold member oh
the first two are some of the best and
you know he created all that wrote
direct i mean he dude created
all of that think about all he did he
played
multiple characters wrote did he direct
him
did he direct us i know he produced but
he he he
created all the character but but like
for me jay roach
jay roach for me those movies to have
think of how many trilogies are good
from
one through three god you know and they
were
good all of them are very rare
you know another one that goes under the
radar you know obviously i have kids so
i'm hot on this subject
but uh the transylvanias that adam
sandler did i think that it's the most
uh success he's had at the box office
the three of those
are so good i know your kids are older
yeah dude transparent kids yeah dude
your grandpa
yeah so translating you one two and
three might be the best one they're
so damn well done i'm gonna tell you
something and i'm glad to hear you say
this
because when i had kids and i would say
to my friends man you gonna watch some
of these cartoons they're not bad they
were like
like shut the [ __ ] up don't try to bring
me into you
into your little group i know but as a
dad and but it's also like
but i'm also not the dad that anything
my son does i'm like dude that's the
best ever
like he drew this thing it was awful
right he's four it's [ __ ] terrible
he's
let's put on the fridge i go this isn't
fridge quality
this isn't fresh you know this shouldn't
be on the fridge you know when
something should be on the fridge and
this ain't it bubba dude and he's like
really i'm like no if you do a good one
it's gonna be it's gonna make the fridge
yeah fridge is his hall of fame right
yeah this is the this isn't hall of fame
this is the inside of your closet
yeah dude where nobody else sees it
except for you when you open it up
that's what i thought and i said did you
put a lot of time in this he goes no i
went you took about one minute
and did this now he went on the fridge
that's not fridge quality
when i was and i would always tell
people this is good parenting and i've
had people argue with me
my brother right above me is a great
artist and i wanted to
do when growing up do what he did yeah
so one day he was drawn to superheroes
and i was like i'm gonna draw some too
he draw original
and my dad this is the type of dude my
dad is my brother walks in drops his
thing goes what do you think that he's
like jonathan
you have a future as an artist like this
is original the definition is amazing
how old is he
he was probably at the time
no no no no nine eight or nine
but good like real and it was like this
is really good and
your personality comes through the
drawings like it's really good right
so i bring something in for my dad and
my dad goes just like this he goes
yeah this isn't for you i know what he
goes no art's not for you he said you
can keep doing it but that's
it's never going to get any better than
that that's great parenting great paper
i never wasted another minute of another
day for you but the parents are like you
can do this like no no you can't
i could pick out we could go to a park
right now i could pick out
20 kids that are not going to be good
swimmers you will attend i think
because you you had kids so you know
this but it's interesting because
especially with
my background in sports like when
my son was playing soccer i can tell you
right now which kid should continue with
sports and which
it's at a very young age just like oh no
dude it's not happening there was a
chapter in my song
you're talking four i'm like yeah i
ain't it there's a chapter in my book
called your son is not derek jeter
because i
coached i coached my son and i played
college baseball
and i'm going to tell you something the
difference between me in a pro oh you
played college baseball yeah
we're at a place called trinity in san
antonio you've heard of it the
difference between me
and a and i was a decent
i played center and left field the
difference between me and somebody who
could play
even division one or major league
baseball is
so vast especially in baseball so
i would watch people and they would be
like hey so what do you think my son
needs
to do to you know really have a chance
i'm like chance at what
did you see him he's he's got his glove
on his head in the outfield
he's chasing a butterfly he's he's not
this isn't his thing but there was a
dude here's the other thing you should
know if you're in pop
water football or i'm sorry if you're in
papawan or baseball
and your son plays center field or right
field he's no good no
nobody can hit it out there eventually
him out there because the ball is never
going to get there
eventually every i bet you every
major league baseball player my guess
started out playing
shortstop and pitcher 100 percent right
we're catchers yeah yeah they're like
somewhere in there what's also like in
pop warner you're if you're the real
athletic one you're probably playing
quarterback even though you're not gonna
be tom brady you're running back but
you're
the athletic kid where they can make
sure they trust you that's the thing is
and eventually you get dispersed around
the field
but the out you put the athletes where
the athletes need to go yes
and so i would always like there was a
guy used to come and used to come
in his you know the old pe shorts he
would show up
and he would be yelling at his kid his
kid who
benny benny who one day lay down
in left field crying because he thought
he had killed a butterfly in the
outfield yep can't have that
and he was crying hysterically by the
way let me tell you the funniest thing
his dad comes out and kneels
because he's crying certainly i come out
his dad comes up betty get up he's doing
that [ __ ] i'm like hey man i got it
chill dude he goes betty get up
and so he comes out and he comes and he
does the coach squat like
this he's talking to his son or
something and one of the other kids goes
and i forget we'll just call him mr
benny i don't give his last name mr
benny
i see something sticking out of your
pants one of his nuts
are like dude i'm like listen man you're
traumatizing
sir bumblebee tuna your balls are
hanging out it's like
you're traumatizing everybody you're
clean your kids yeah dude your son is
like i hope i was
wish i was really dead but why first of
all why are you wearing those shorts
you watch baseball now especially you
know just came back i do
just because i like watching sports
man i like watching sports and you know
obviously pandemic we're dealing with
all this but
there's never been if you're a sports
fan now's with it's without a crowd and
can take it with a grain of salt but
it's like
we've never had all the sports firing at
the same time then if you're a sports
fan there's so much to watch right now
what do you think
and i for me there's some sports i
really like it i know this is just me
and i'm not as
obviously i'm a peripheral peripheral
ufc fan
sure i like it without the fans i like
hearing it me too i like hearing the
fight i almost prefer it which is
strange
i prefer it so much more
for me honestly i can concentrate on the
fight more
and like what's happening i love in some
of the body shots
that i wasn't sure that i wasn't sure
i'm like does that really hurt when you
hear it i'm like i know it's great god
also you hear the coaching yeah
like it's i i think there's not a better
product as far as sports go
without a crowd what sport do you think
as a player
misses the crowd the most that's a good
question
it's gonna be football because if if
you're
let's say you're i will use my alumni
university of colorado and you're
playing alabama and alabama's this
powerhouse
and you're you're playing at cu you're
playing a home field advantage
sometimes you can deal with the momentum
and it might take your team to another
level where
you get momentum and you get a fumble
then you you know throw a password
touchdown and you got the momentum
well now there's no momentum yeah that
the good team's probably gonna whoop
your ass it's all 99 times out of 100
yeah like it's like the good team's
gonna win because there's now there's no
momentum there's no crowd
to inspire the kids like yeah especially
nfl is as pro as it gets they don't give
a [ __ ] about crowd
nothing they're pros do you think they
don't you think basketball do you think
the bad you think the best
basketball this basketball is a it's a
better product i think now that
basketball is in this bubble
and everyone's had a chance to get
healthy and there's no crowd
so for a team like the clippers or the
76ers 76ers
were awful on the road yeah they're a
team on the road and bj simmons was hurt
now they've had rest there's no road
games everything's just neutral
and they're great they were the best
team at home so it's like now they're a
contender
you know what i'm saying so now crazy
and then oh the la clippers when the
clippers played the lakers in la
even if they said it was a clippers home
game and the clippers
it said clippers on the on the court it
was still a lakers home game
now that doesn't matter now the clippers
they don't give a [ __ ] now nobody's
booing or cheering so the clippers to me
would be the favorite
i gotta tell you i've been watching some
of the basketball
and i wish so the mics that they used to
have closer to the floor
it feels like they took away a little
bit you know why they didn't want you to
hear them swearing correct yeah because
well
they picked up on lebron a little bit
and i think it's good again a reason why
i like no crowd and a lot of stuff i
want to hear the trash talk dude
i want to hear the trash shop i know but
they they if you notice when the games
fir like
last week thursday night when the lakers
uh played the clippers or whoever it was
lebron they people didn't realize how
much was [ __ ] talkers yes he was saying
[ __ ] and blah blah and people like oh
this is great
now they're like uh uh cause guys are
gonna say some
[ __ ] they do but but but you know what
that's like [ __ ]
oh come on my thing is let it go i want
to hear the [ __ ]
here's here's what's interesting you
tell me where you fall on this so
baseball played with it a little bit
where you know everybody took a knee and
you know the brave thing to do now is
actually standing for the anthem
which is insane the world we live in
right now to each its own
but no one's gonna gone harder in the
paint than the nba as far as mixing
politics and sports yeah so when you
turn it on
everybody's taking a knee unless you're
uh george popovich
are you know very few guys uh are
standing for the anthem
but it's black lives matter on the court
i'm fine with that that's what everyone
do
they're jerseys now it's a uh black
lives matter on the jerseys or
defund the police where the hell they
want to put on their jerseys so now
politics are mixed in with nba
because what the nba is doing is because
it's a younger audience they're
listening to social media yeah they're
going man we got to do something here
but they don't realize social media
isn't the end-all be-all because
1 in 50 people on our social media you
know that yeah so if you walk outside
right now 150
one in 50 is on twitter one in 50. so
this
woke crowd that doesn't speak for the
majority but the nba
is trying to make those people online
happy so they're doing
mix mixing politics in sports well what
they don't realize is that's not the
real world it's important but it's not
the end-all be
yeah so more people watch the opening to
the major league baseball than they did
open to the nba which has never happened
before ever
i i think a couple things now here's my
thing
er i'll i'm going to watch it regardless
i don't care what the hell they do
but just based off the ratings if you're
uh the commissioner of the nba or your
nba owner
you got to decide what's important
because if it's bottom dollar
you can't mix politics in the politics
that because the nation has spoke and
they didn't tune in because they're sick
of it
here's my thing man and that doesn't
mean that the nation doesn't think black
lives matter
that's not important they just don't
want it at that one time
when lebron is facing kauai they want
one outlet where they can just
watch basketball see i see all of that i
also see like you know it's so funny
what we consider to be political
because the fact that we think black
lives matter
is poli is is now considered politics
is oh is is so crazy to me because that
means
it's drawn are we saying that statement
you have to be on one side or other
politically which i think is
crazy for what they what what it's
supposed to mean
but who created that i know but here's
the other thing the president united
states here's the other thing like
i i have articles of clothing that have
the american flag on them
do you know that when i wear those now i
and i walk down the street people will
scream [ __ ] trump to me
because the american flag has somehow
become
political also somehow the if you're
wearing an american flag
you're you're automatically an extreme
right dude i'll do one better for you so
when i get corona right
i get corona my doctor goes
this is insane this is where we're at in
the world he goes
hey where do you i don't know where you
stand politically but what do you think
of hydrochloroquine
yeah i go what he goes i don't know you
know
if you're anti-trump you're probably not
going to take hydrochloroquine because
he says it's good i go
dude if you told me sticking corn in the
cob up my
ass yeah would get this over with faster
i'm going to do that if you told me
paint my face orange like trump
would get me over this fast i'm gonna do
it
when do politics come into medicine yeah
don't don't but because
trump said hey hydrochloroquine helps
with
uh uh corona people went oh [ __ ]
hydrochloroquine it's like whoa
for a ton of people it's actually worked
it's so
crazy and that's what i mean like to me
the fact that the american flag or black
lives matter
turns political and that you had to ask
me that where do i
it's it's crazy but i will tell you
where i stand
for me when i do stand up i i have man
i have strong political and social views
i don't put them in my stand-up because
i'm not a political pundit that's not my
job save that for bill maher right
that's not my job
not and i'm not bashing the people who
do it that's what but that's not
for me i i don't i don't personally mis
mix my job and my now it's not saying
that i don't
tell you what my political views are but
just not while i'm doing my job
i agree with you but also i forget who
said it but when you do that when you
when you
when you're gonna do stand up and you
take a political bit
you're already cutting the room in half
yeah because half the people
half and half so half are going to love
it half are going to hate it so right
when you take a political stand and
stand up
you're cut the room in half also i don't
have
a unique view on politics where i can
add it to my stand-up
that's going to make people like dave
chappelle
amazing i agree he has a a political
view or a viewpoint where people go
jesus christ that was amazing and really
funny
i'm not smart enough for that either the
thing that's not that guy the thing that
i would say though
about especially the nba guys is
if i was lebron james and i had that
platform
in this particular thing whatever it was
was so important to me life or death
important to me
of how i grew up and the people that i
know in my neighborhood i would use my
platform
which is what they're doing yes so
that's i get it so i get it i totally
get it if i
run the nba the balancing act
i have to really do every day is
yes the consumer but also
the player the product the price is the
players and there's no consumer without
it
it's not so let me do one better than
that so if you're the commissioner
you're lebron james
lebron james supposedly the rumor which
is a pretty validated he has a billion
dollar contract with nike yeah
all his shoes are made in china when he
does space jam 2
it the way that things have become
successful is china yes
so you want to talk about rights and
civil rights and what's right
and you want to get on your platform and
preach black lives matter stuff like
that
yet you know that you're in business
with china who is suppressing and taking
away
civil liberties from hong kong yet you
don't say [ __ ]
if i want to go on the nba website and
create a a lakers jersey
i can't you know the one thing i could
put [ __ ] the cops on there
i could put josh sucks dick on the back
of my shirt you know what i can't put
i've seen those shirts you know what i
can't but those are great churches
you know what i can't put yeah free hong
kong
i can't put anything on hong kong on the
jury but you want to
push down my throat civil rights here in
america
yet in hong kong if you turn on the
[ __ ] tv right now they're waving
american flags saying help us yes yet
the nba has
that you know they get billions billions
billions of dollars from china
yet they don't give a [ __ ] about that so
when you take your political opinion
it's hard for me to buy into it because
you don't get because you're picking and
choosing
who should have civil rights let me play
which i it's hard for me to [ __ ] with
let me play devil's advocate but i still
watch
yeah i have nike's on right now i have
an iphone yeah
let me and by the way good job on those
iphones uh i really like mine
it's more steve jobs but yeah but not
making them let me play devil's advocate
for you
go ahead so say
oh the education system here in america
is terrible
which it is well public why pub school
in l.a
okay send you ken pogba but say you had
to send your kid to pub school yes
would you be fighting for bettering pub
schools in la
or would you look at mexico too while
you were fighting for the ones in la
now is mexico giving me billions of
dollars
because then i'm not gonna say [ __ ] but
i'm asking you do you care equally i
know
that's the thing like what's going on
right now so so so for me i'm cleaning
up my house before i go to your house
but what happens if you don't give a
[ __ ] about the other house i'm not
saying that they do
and i'm saying a hundred percent all i'm
saying all of that money
matters all the money back but yes all
the money
but if you're in l.a and you're pointing
your finger at me
and you're saying civil rights matter
school let's say for
schools matters schools matter i'm like
i know but you take all this money from
mexico
and you're saying schools don't matter
over there but here they matter just
because you're here
totally get it and he's he's a hundred
percent
they i'm sure somebody in the office was
in the commissioner's office was like
yo everybody pull it back on china well
but the notice also lebron is one of the
few players who didn't put black lives
matter on his jersey
you know what lebron's jersey says james
23
yeah because i think he knows if he did
that there's gonna be more heat his way
here's what i will say i don't think
that dude is scared
complicated yes because i think lebron's
like
what do you want me to do but dude
here's the best thing about you saying
it's complicated thank god you said that
because
i'm gonna switch my hat to you oh man
it's taking a hot second to get here by
the way
all of these topics that we're talking
about whether it's coronavirus black
lives matter whatever
it's all complicated the problem i think
that we have in today's society
is nobody thinks complicated nobody
thinks things are gray
it's black or it's white that's the
problem and so there's no there's no
discussion of yes that's true
but there's this it's it's it's you have
to pick a side
and you have to agree with everything
this side says or we're kicking you to
the other side yeah
or that side evil yes no they're not
evil they have actually some good ideas
yes
maybe that you just don't agree with
them on certain things like you could be
the most
pro-biting guy in the world and policy
and you're so democratic dude we i don't
give a [ __ ] me neither i don't care what
you could be pro-trump pro-biden pro
whatever
as long as you're not racist or hurting
somebody i don't care dude
you're still my friend this is where
some people they're like oh i can't dude
he's he's too he's too this he's too
libertarian's too conservative i'm like
i don't care he's a good person dude i
miss your viewpoint
my the way you grew up might have made
you this way or this
way and you agree with that which that's
your decision i always go back to mike
vick
you know i remember when that news came
out about vic with the dog fighting
i was as disgusted as everybody else
and then i spoke to a friend of mine who
grew up in alabama
and he goes hey man i know that you're
going off on this but let me just tell
you
i'm not saying it's right i'm just
saying i didn't grow up where people had
dogs out of pets
yep i grew up i grew up knowing this is
what dogs did yeah
they went and they got the [ __ ] that i
hunted and we fought them
and that they weren't in the house yeah
that was it and so i've grown to know
better now
but i didn't know better for a long time
my grandmother
my brother has only ever dated black
girls my grandmother called her colored
and we were like you can't say that she
was like why not i didn't say the other
word
yep and i was like neither just so you
know we're fifty years past
she didn't know that you but she's her
perspective from her perspective she was
saying the correct
here's the problem too if let's say she
went on let's say it was today's
day and age and she called somebody
colored on social media
she's a racist no one wants to educate
him like whoa
this is why you can't say that all of a
sudden you're you're off the island
you know man i'm i'm jewish right and um
you probably didn't know that before you
asked me to come down but i uh that's
stuff with deshawn jackson you must be a
huge nick cannon fan
yeah yeah but same with the cannon all
that stuff
i was bummed to see people calling for
those people to be canceled me too
what it needs is a conversation so
wouldn't and i was so glad to see what
julian edelman did because i said the
same thing
don't cancel desean jackson educate him
get him to new york
get into some synagogues let him talk to
some rabbis
if you really want to talk about people
who are and have been persecuted and
continue to be
we're with you man maybe not as much in
this country although anti-semitism is
on a rise
i get more i was in lot this is the last
time i was in myrtle beach
i was in a meet and greet and this dude
came up to me with his friends and i
could tell he was gonna say something
shitty because he kept looking over his
shoulder and laughing
right and he goes to me man he goes i
never thought you guys were that you
people were that funny i go you people
and he called me he goes you know kites
he said with a t kite
because he thought [ __ ] was kite and i
go what'd you call me he goes kite
like i was gonna get mad i go okay
because my my
in my mind was like if the if the
anti-semites in south carolina call
jews kites i got no problem
but like so brazen let me pee real quick
and
carry the sun we are brought to you by
the one the only me undies me
undies the best underwear on the planet
the softest modal i'm talking about
micro modal
they're so damn soft oh it's a hug for
your nuts
my undies has this brilliant thing
called undies membership where
every month the softest undies that's
ever appeared on your body
arrives at your door step the
convenience factor is clutch you never
have to leave the house
and wonder oh man what am i doing nope
you know exactly what you're doing with
the underwear game oh and you also get
site-wide savings early access free
shipping it's fantastic
meundies are offering a range of sizes
from extra small
to four xl from the thick boys
where the me undies on your bike ride
think boy bike club for xl what's up man
mandy's has a great offer for you guys
for any first-time purchasers you get 15
off and free shipping
you got to give this softness a try
especially because they have 100
satisfaction guarantee
to get 50 off your first order and free
shipping 100
satisfaction guaranteed go to
meundies.com
fighter that's meundies.com fighter
yeah it's crazy and that guy just was
like uh
it was just normal for him that it's
just uh to me it's a bummer because you
know obviously
i'm a white dude in america even though
i look mexican but uh
like i was rogan had on uh the the
korean guy
um david joe david joe do you know him
chilling i don't know of him you're a
fan of him yeah
i mean i'm love the guy absolutely love
me listen rogan
and uh he talks about the racism he
experienced
and he was talking about how he was
walking with his dad on the street and a
guy did the asian
face to him you know eyes thing to him
and a guy he said
he walks like i don't know for two hours
every day he says you walk and some guy
yelled out go back to your country yeah
and i'm just baffled by it because
obviously i mean i love your guy's
opinion on him like
people still do that and i i think
you know and he talked about like
trump's giving people an
okay especially go at asians because he
called it the you know the chinese
uh the congress i heard kung flu which
sounds terrible
yeah he did say that and so it it so if
you're the leader of the free world the
leader of america does that then
everyone's like
i guess it's okay so then these races
come out yeah so when he said that i'm
like people still
do that [ __ ] listen you know when you're
such a bummer man
when you're when you've got dudes or
people chanting jews will not replace us
in that charlotte was that
charlottesville is that where that was
charlottesville
and you have a president come out and
think about what you just had you had a
group of people
now they were they had tiki torches so
how i wasn't too scared of people i'm
like are those
gonna keep the bugs away from you these
are the ones you have in the backyard
but
for somebody not to come out and just
say hey we can't
have this it okay's it it makes it it
gives them that free pass yeah yeah
because if trump's doing it it's like oh
it's just it's so it's it just to me
it's i've experienced more anti-semitism
probably in the last three years than i
have
and i dude i went to college in texas in
the 90s
jesus christ it's just crazy yeah yeah
it's really it's like when i heard him
say that i'm like
what the [ __ ] this isn't la it's going
on i can't i can't um
but part of it i'm just naive because i
i don't deal with it you know but you're
also even if you were
asian you're an enormous person
but chin's huge too do you do have you
gotten any of anything chin like
as of late no but i did tell you once i
once we started walking to the markets
one who was like in the thick of the
coronavirus
people did seem like they would look at
me and just you know move away further
than they would with
other people dude when i was i i was in
i think it was chicago
and this uh uh middle eastern dude
picked us up a great kid he was like 19
or he might have been 21 he's been
driving
oh i'm sorry that when when september
11th happened he was 21 when he picked
this up he was like whatever 32 now
he's been doing it for a long time he's
saying how how much he hustles and
he's bragging how much he makes off uber
i was like god damn yeah i mean
kids balls but he's exhausted he's
driving because he's
paying for his mom and all this stuff
and uh we just started talking uh and
you know he's a middle eastern dude and
he goes man i'll tell you
you ever have any psychos get in the car
and try and fight he goes dude
when september 11th happened there was a
hit out on muslim and
people in the middle east he goes i pick
some guys up and
i'm just driving and you know i might
you know they have a picture in the
middle of the car like a taxi and as the
things hanging down
because i'm driving with some normal
music and they just start [ __ ]
wailing away on me
and started yelling you know usa he's
like yeah i was born in chicago you more
yeah yeah
yeah i have nothing to do with it i
gotta tell you
and i haven't thought about this since
so on september
13 2001 i was living in
sherman oaks and do you remember
they were sending out on the news if you
see somebody
in a uniform but they look reported
middle eastern make sure you ask
them what they're doing in your
neighborhood oh
no so there was a dude with
a supposed cable and you and he was at
his job man
but when he got out of that van
he was saying from the street everybody
there was somebody on the yeah i'm just
here to do the cable
cause i'm just here to do the cable and
they were like let me see your id and
he's like okay
but he was scared there were people on
the front yard
watching him do his job like this dude
from spectrum
all of a sudden isis was going to hit la
meda
on sure you know 1500 lameda the house
on lameta
we need to plant a bomb they're you know
just scared and they don't know what to
do and it's like
is that dead uh nicotine you want
something no no no no
i dipped for a long time like this is
like these are nicotine pouches so it's
like uh they're
tobacco-free were you a dipper or never
neither neither i listened to a podcast
on how nicotine uh
helps with like if you've suffered brain
trauma or ct you know
yeah they've seen like as you get older
the one thing that they've seen in
smokers
it's not because the cigarettes but it's
nicotine from cigarettes
one thing they all have in common is
there something like 90 percent
less likely to have dementia because the
nicotine what it does for your brain is
insane
yeah so i was like man how can i get
nicotine i saw spray then i saw these
tobacco-free uh pouches i was worried
i'll try those
i don't know i feel smarter let me ask
you something i
need to know something i can't remember
a single name off
any show
someone asked me i just go well the guy
and then the girl like
nate was i don't know what that is
character names never
i'm bad with ufc names unless it's a
major star i'm bad with it
it's like uh i don't like my brain just
like not important
you dude we're doing our best you don't
need to remember that
i'm the same way i think mine is weed
induced
but but then also like it's like my
brain must be okay because
if if tonight you asked me to do an hour
of material i can remember my
material i don't write it down your
brain tells you what's important my
brain goes yeah dude
no we got enough going on yeah you don't
need to know the name of [ __ ]
the cast members on yellowstone no yeah
you're good your
your brain makes the noise that whitney
does at the beginning of our podcast
okay that's it that you're good you're
good i'm not important bubba yeah
not for you i i don't i i'm terrible
with names
but if you're asking me what was the
name of the person or you know you know
absolutely terrible with lyrics for
songs ah the worst
i make them up oh i do my girl goes
my cousin blah blah blast coming over i
go have i met her she goes
are you [ __ ] me we've been together
for six
you you've met her multiple times i go
what's her name
and then i go what's her husband's name
she's like unbelievable
you went on a bike ride with that guy
i'm like yeah i didn't know his name
yeah i called him hey yeah yeah
yeah you hear that she goes you're the
worst i'm like no no you gotta remember
my brain only stores so much
so my brain goes you really don't need
to know that phoebe
did you tell her i can either remember
your cousin's name or yours yeah
you pick your choice i have one spot
left do you
do you i have dying to know this because
i was watching some
ufc over the weekend some highlight some
clips sure when you're
getting when you're in the ring or after
the ring after getting hit
that many times is that and immediately
after does that ever enter
i hope there's no permanent not well
especially when i was fighting like ct
and brain trauma wasn't really even
conversation
like it wasn't it was like oh you got
your bell rung like you're fine that was
the term when i was growing up like you
got your bell running like i remember
in football they would put me in on
certain plays just to see me collide
with this guy brian ew who
played for the chicago bears and was the
captain of our team but it was called uh
a 94 power power power toss
so the fullback would just run as fast
can and the outside linebacker be there
and would just
it'd be like two battering rams but the
entire team and coaches would stop
because everyone would look at the play
the f would give away the play so the
guy's like oh here we go
and the whole team was just watch i
remember just like us bashing heads as
far as we can
every week twice a week and now i think
i'm like what the [ __ ] were we doing let
me ask you something and then in
fighting it's like
oh you got your bell wrong just you know
just lay low like drink water
what's happening in the ring when you
get your bell ring you don't think about
it
but aren't you trying to regain your
senses
or you yeah yeah it's like your survival
like you ought to come back you're just
trying to buy
time shake off the cobwebs as they call
it like you're just trying to
maneuver so you don't get hit again it's
stupid i remember it wasn't go i
remember
i would be in the ring and bruce buffer
would announce my name
or he would announce somebody like let's
say he announced matt matron's name
first
and they announced mine and as he
announced my name i would have my head
go what the [ __ ] am i doing
as he's shouting in my face i'm like
what the [ __ ] am i doing
what am i doing i i it's not good it
baffles me
that if i knew this morning i'm getting
up and going to work
and someone's gonna punch me in the face
multiple times
at my job it's the toughest job in the
world well
how many times do boxers get hit in the
face
in a fight well i mean that's the point
right i mean
hundreds that's like saying how often
does michael phelps get wet
that's what i'm saying like that is your
job to and i people i know
there are a lot of people like this
[ __ ] that's not your job either
[ __ ] okay you know what i mean
so you call me a [ __ ] all you want
the other thing that you know the the
way people should have more respect for
fighters is like
let's say you're a guy like uh somebody
coming up you can name anyone but let's
say you beat the number eight guy in the
world
let's say you're ranked number 10 you
beat the number eight guy in the world
and you go on vacation you know
that as soon as you get back there's
this monster right number six that
they're gonna pair you up with and you
know how [ __ ] tough he is
and be like oh just relax take it easy
but you just it's like
it's like if you got bullied at school
and you know the next day you gotta see
that bully
it's that all the time for me it was
it was like all the time just like oh
you just have that pit in your stomach
you're like oh god he's so good
and then and then you beat him and then
he beat him you beat the number six guy
well you know the number five guy
you know the number four guy you're
looking through the list just like
wow does anybody ever and so
one of the reasons i like sitting down
with you is i'm gonna ask a lot of
layman's questions
no please that other people would never
ask does anybody this is going to sound
dumb and maybe it's just the little
brother in me
thinking about how to win fights yeah
but does anybody ever decide all right
i'm not showering for a week i'm not
brushing my teeth and i'm not washing
them wouldn't it matter
wouldn't matter is she in there now it's
a lot you like that sketching was like
[ __ ] and then you just beat the [ __ ] out
of them
but so so that doesn't matter that that
doesn't if someone came in it was like i
no i remember the only time like i
remember when i was fighting crow cop i
was like god he smells funny
and i was like and then this is wall my
nose is broken
we're in the middle it's the biggest
fight in my career it's in uh
new jersey sold out crowd jon jones
fighting shogun for his first world
title
biggest fight in my life he's a legend i
remember my nose is shattered i'm
bleeding everywhere
and we're there and the crowd's like
chanting whatever
thinking god he smells funny and then i
swear to god i'm going
i'm thinking look at this listen i'm
thinking
i'm thinking god he smells funny and
then and in my head i go
he's probably croatian so it's just it's
it's just different you know like does
he maybe he thinks i smell funny
and then it could douche elbow on there
all right let's stop thinking about that
listen
you know what's funny about that because
i know you've done this on stage also
have you been uh because on stage i
people ask me all the time like
i'm gonna leave you alone let me show
you get your head together for this
stage i'm like i'm just walking out
there
yeah i'm doing my thing i don't need you
yeah you gotta be here up until the
point they
yeah but does it ever happen to you like
especially saturday night late shows for
me
where i'll be in the middle of a bit but
in my brain i'm thinking about something
else okay
my flight leaves at 8 am 100 you're
gonna be at the airport at six it's
cruise control
you're you're not present no ah there's
something with me where i'll be in the
again maybe i've done six shows i'll
never forget this in calgary
like oh you want to do seven shows three
day three three shows on saturday
and by that late show on saturday night
i remember i'm in the middle of my bed
i'm saying it verbally but in my head
i'm like god dude you still got this to
go
i'm checking off like you dude you're
not even halfway yeah and it's like and
then
are they gonna have the chinese food but
you've been doing it so much you're just
i'm doing my bit i'm doing a good job
because i've done it a million times now
it's the third show so you're in cruise
control but as it's coming out of my
mouth and my head i'm like i'm gonna
chase priority so then i'm gonna do that
yeah
it's so weird because you're you're not
present
but then if you like someone says
something and throws you off they're
like
wait what yeah you'll lose your where
you're at in your bit i
it's so strange i sometimes i'll catch
myself
and i'll be talking to myself in my head
and then it'll make me laugh
i'll be like hey what the [ __ ] am i
doing sorry yeah i'll i'll say to the
crowd
i was talking to you but in my head it's
so weird something
else was happening so i remember i was
just doing the show for
uh complex and they're going over the
whole thing
and i'm interviewing the guy it's going
great and
in my head i'm like there has to be
somebody better at this than like
out of all the people in my head i'm
like what the [ __ ] am i doing
i like out of all the guys yeah trust me
i'm like i'm fighting with my like what
the [ __ ] are you doing dude
i i got all the guys i have to tell you
man it's so strange i
i that's why i love live it's go back to
that tv
because whatever happens i let i embrace
what's happening
at that moment yeah and so i and for me
it makes every show
i'm going to cleveland this weekend
right are you at uh polarities
oh my god my favorite club i love that
too with nick
wow dude the food there is the best so
they have a legit restaurant and if you
sell out he gives you the bat yeah i get
that bad
the bats in my basement there it is
there it is um
you're at hilarity's uh this weekend six
seven today thursday
friday saturday and thirteenth fourth oh
okay we're not doing uh i think that one
get canceled at the moment so you're
there yeah my irvine just got canceled
yeah
that's california though what's the
capacity like in hilarities
you know what i have to check the
contract i think it's changed a couple
of times
it's weird because it'll go you know 150
300
200 400 you know honestly for me 70.
it's like you're not coming out there
just me and you yeah yeah three
the staff what dude yeah
it's just you and the staff bubba they
need money man buy drinks
dude what do you think about this for an
idea tell me if this works
because do you miss selling merch oh
yeah
well but i i sell merch i sell thick boy
bike merch yeah
and it's like my pride in but can you
sell it at the shows thick boy bike club
no because of the shows they haven't
been able to they haven't had us doing
merch lines
oh because they don't want people what
about this for an idea what if i
have the wait staff
they would they're going back and forth
so the wait staff
during the show you would buy the merch
pre-show
and i give the pre-show yes
and i give the pre-show they should uh
should pose
a b or c the price and then while they
come by if people want it they go a b or
c
you and then they pay and i give the
staff percentage
of the money brilliant i think because
merch i like that merch is i have this
i'm obsessed with murder yeah
not because the money i make because i'm
in the fashion i'm in the clothes
all right my like dude my new line is
fire so dope dude i just did oh blood we
can talk about i wasn't gonna do it by a
few whiskeys you're the best
so brian is gone
so uh with think boy uh bike club merch
we
just we it's coming they take a while to
produce probably like six weeks away
we did a collab with specialized which
is the biggest biking company in the
world
so specialized and then thick boy bike
club my team
we all collaborated on biking gear for
actual like real bike gear
it's thick boy and specialized collab
together
i'm so cranky they sent me the
renderings dude
dude let me ask you do you have this
honest question that [ __ ] fires me up
you gotta reinforce your bicycle seat
like you aren't you like wait oh no i'm
yeah i mean like how
what does it disappear or people like is
he sitting on him you see what i did on
my bike
yes dude i was i'm surprised that didn't
happen
sooner but when i see big dudes on bikes
now i'm always like
this is first of all dude that is carbon
fiber
and it [ __ ] snapped in half
in front of people it was do you know
what the
saddest thing was so you see those
people yeah there's a group of like
hot girls over here and i was like x
games in the house
yeah off the bike like what's up scarf
is on
oh scarf is on like [ __ ] in or tucked
out out okay i'm in a tank top
like what's up girls did this juice
the [ __ ] pedal goes sick yeah off a
rock and you just hear someone go
yeah oh so i like i'm like
wobbling i like wobble dude it's all the
way back there and i just went
i had to walk back pick it up i get on
my bike and like walk in it i'm like oh
my god dude
i get on like one hand like this that is
the last thing especially as part of the
thick boy club
the last thing you want to do is snap
your bicycle
the last thing you want to do is have it
crumble under your weight
oh dude you know dude it's like it's
it's on me like i shouldn't be doing
these jumps but
i'm getting more comfortable with the
bike jumps how much you weigh probably
255 right now
dude i jump and i the bike's all carbon
fiber and i got
the fox shocks on it the best shots you
can get and i i
i can feel it when i when i hit the
ground the whole bike goes
dude have you not seen the body types
the people who ride
bicycles i know the jumps that's where
the thick boy bike club comes from and
there's a bunch of thickies out there
doing the same
[ __ ] dude i will tell you this though
man have you been to portland
oh yeah home of the most arrogant
bicyclist
um in the in road bikers though oh yes
big difference dude you're talking by
the way apple's an orange let's slow
your roll down because i had i had a
bicyclist tell me this too
he said to me i go hey man he said watch
out for bikers i go
let's slow your roll and call yourself a
biker bro don't don't say biker
cyclist yeah a biker has like a
sleeveless
vest and tattoos and commits crimes you
have a bell and a basket [ __ ]
yeah bikers hell's ain't
yeah yeah you are a bicyclist yes and
they are
so arrogant up there they ride in the
middle of the [ __ ] yeah
it's a weird la and again this is this
is road bikers it's a weird like
fraternity
where they think that they have every
privilege in the world
and you got to get out of their way and
they will
shout at you dude yeah like in what
world can you
yell at people it's so strange what i
love is like dude if i hit you with my
car thank you only one of us is gonna be
effective it's not gonna be my car
yeah and and here's the deal my when
they scream at me watch out for bikers
i'm like first of all you need to watch
out for cars [ __ ]
yeah the ones on like um topanga canyon
i'm like
dude this is a one way you [ __ ] you're
in the middle of the road what are you
doing around
corners and [ __ ] like listen i started
with a road bike i almost got hit twice
in one day i'm like i'm out no i'm out
and all the fans like dude get a
mountain bike you [ __ ]
and that's the thing when people when i
hear people like
you need to share the road no dude no
it's a road dude no
i don't it's crazy it's the road this is
that they are
in some cities but i will this is how
many bikes they have in in portland
i saw a bike rack out in front of a
strip club i'm like
if you ride a bicycle to strip club bro
turn around and go home
you you can't show up sweaty they might
be with that
with your with your you know how they
cuff their and clean your head because
they've got the clip-ons cleaned
up how do you expand it the spandex
makes sense are you getting a laptop you
ever got a lab dance and spandex shorts
i'm not
then you ain't living i have you nope
but i can imagine what it's like yeah
man i i will tell you there's nothing
like some people were
uh sweats to the strip club that's a bad
for that reason there was a buddy of
mine okay so uh
when we were in for my wedding we had my
wedding on bourbon street well down in
new orleans but we went to bourbon
street the night before
my wife was there we went to strip club
and together we went to strip club
together but my friends went to all your
friends and her friends
just her and my friends oh wow and so
this dude goes to the boom boomer and
gets a dance
and he comes out and sits down and his
wife is back at the hotel
i'm not going to say his name i'll just
make up a name do i know him and no
no it's a buddy of mine if i went to
college i go hey john you're all do you
know jamie
yeah i go hey john and he goes yeah i go
how was that dance
and he goes great man i go hey man you
know they got black lights here
and he goes yeah and i go look at your
pants no
my man spider-man dude i was like you
yeah man
spider-man all over his face yeah dude i
was like you gotta clean that [ __ ] up
before you go
home bro and he was like oh my god i go
it's you
an idea and yeah dude like it's it's the
black light that's your
wife like you guys are more oh no i said
get out of here before she's
oh she's gonna see it no i'm gonna get
out of here before she sees you and i'm
like what are you first of all
also are you eight why are you coming in
your pants
she couldn't get it out for you like
what what what you're in the boom boom
room dude
and it's new orleans yeah man there's
no rules down here why is that in your
pants
she's looking crazy yeah it was a bad
move do you know
when i was in college three times
i tried stripping mail stripping what
you gained a lot of momentum in my book
three times i tried three times
the first time that was enough for me
well after the first time you didn't
learn what happened the first
well the first time hold on did you go
to strip club to audition
uh there was a guy that i had met who
listen i had
i grew up with no money and i was
working times are tough
i was working in the bowling alley at
the school not making money not making
money
also not a real uh not a job that has a
lot of respect
behind it no not a lot of women are like
oh you work in the bowling alley at the
school can you get me a size seven
yeah yeah it's not we're not so i was
like what am i gonna do i wanna make a
little money maybe meet some women
first of all i had no idea how women
act in those places it's so much more
insane than
oh it's like piranhas when you drop
chicken so much more but
like i have these skinny little legs
they don't care but they're like super
skinny they i was getting manhandled
like they were they were like they're
going to want to hold oh you actually
did the damn thing oh yeah i thought you
auditioned for like
no audition bruno i talked to this dude
and he was like yo man come up he was
like can you dance i'm like i'm all
right
he goes all you got to do is just kind
of swing your dick around
and i was like okay what did you wear
well he
what his thing was he was like you got
to pick out your outfit and your song
oh oh so song what song dude there's so
many good ones
but this is the 90s bro you know yeah
would you come out molly crew man
what song come on doctor feel good i was
coming man
yeah and you're you're in a speedo i was
in pants that tore away
that's right oh the first night i did it
dude i didn't
i didn't get them all the way down like
a kick
yeah i had to sit down on the third
second like just give me a minute
but um is it packed with girls
it was packed i he was like how do you
feel about them holding you and i was
like what do you mean
and he was like well you're going to be
smaller than everybody and some of those
women are going to want to hug you or
hold you
yes it's not like tens are there you
know it's like
it's women that could hold me dude it's
it's tlc 610
600 pound life who are super thirsty now
yes and that's
listen at the time i'm i'm still in
pretty decent shape
but the time i'm walking around four
percent body fat
probably oh they loved it oh they love
some josh come on
the wolf man coming out come on dude so
you hit that stage and did you have
nerves in the back
ah well i took a hit of ecstasy oh oh
yeah because i was like he was like you
might need this your first time and i
was like cool
sounds like a nice guy for what you're
dealing with
like at least he was like dude he was
grooming me yeah he's grooming you yeah
so did you have to get the the the dick
kind of fired up
no did you have to rev the engine just a
tad i i
i enhanced meaning but here's the thing
i
because he was like some guys kind of
jerk off a little bit
but then you know it goes away yeah
especially when you're on stage like
when you're on stage or you're about to
fight or do something athletic my dick
goes
retreat yeah they go in like a turtle so
i go what can i do to help it
and he said you know there are some
things that you can put around it
i guess the best thing i could it's kind
of like a fleshlight but just for the
shaft
it just makes it look girthier because
you're not taking your dick
again i like this guy yeah yeah yeah
everything you're saying makes a lot of
sense but what he didn't tell me
was that you're gonna get lightheaded a
great but you're gonna get a
it's they're going to be aggressive the
women it's a frenzy it's a great it's
shark week it's aggressive
it's a shark and so the first that's why
when i went back
and i told him i'm so glad i'm taking
ecstasy because i like people touching
me
but they'll get in it they'll get in it
fingers did you so
cody oh i'm dude by the way i'm sure
this happens to you
meet and greets you telling me nobody
grabs your ass or your dick i get
sexually assaulted every meet and greet
me too i just take it i mean i'm just
like whatever dude they grabbed my ass
like me too every every time and it's
usually in front of their husband i'm
like
definitely not comfortable with this i'm
not gonna terry crews it and you
write an article but but i'm with the
same that the dude it's not comfortable
the guy doesn't give a [ __ ] here's the
thing it's usually a woman who's like
i'm not letting him in the picture
yes she's like no you take the picture
yeah she goes no he's gonna take the
picture like
well why don't you both just take it and
i'm like here we go yep and i know i'm
gonna get and i take it yeah
yeah i shut up and i take it you know
what i told one guy once
because his wife grabbed me by the ass
but the middle finger
went standard when it's a straight
[ __ ] the standard
and i told him i go hey man smell that
finger later yeah
i've done three shows and i ate about
six pounds of [ __ ] sweet and sour
chicken from yuck yuck yeah
smell that finger yeah you're gonna want
to win for that dude so your first one
you get manhandled bruises
tough no scratches no bruises scratches
scratches scratches
and you came back well did you make good
money that was it
so he he was like this is your first
time out you don't get full dough
you want to come back next time we'll
give you full dough yeah he's a
businessman
he's a businessman he wanted i went back
for phil doman
and but i was like i need to be [ __ ]
up again the third time i did it
i'm like you know what i'm not gonna be
[ __ ] up and i just couldn't do it and
i was like if i
need someone this is [ __ ] up i can't
make i can't do this it's gonna go down
a dangerous run
yeah man because you're just you're
basically rick from rick and morty
hammered
all the time all the time dancing and i
didn't want to do that because i saw
some of those
older dudes who were like yeah man oh
and an
old scallywag at the [ __ ] mail strip
club
you know super tan they look like did
you ever put on all the trt
just [ __ ] died dirty they they all
looked like an
old school wrestler brutus the barber
beefcake yeah they smelled cake powder
oh what was your name oh but tay i went
joss
j-o-s-s they were like you're small make
your name a little more feminine oh
interesting and i was like so so you're
not that small dude
compared to really were there some
beefcakes you gotta figure they were all
thunder down under those boys
have you been there they're beefy dudes
i have not they're beefy
and they've thundered down another beat
and they put on a hell of a show yeah
man
it's a show i was not putting on as much
of this show
i can't imagine i wasn't doing a carton
dance either you know what i'm saying
but i'm trying i was trying to be
schmexy man it's hard to be sexy with
motley crew playing that's why i had no
it's not bite your tongue
really oh my god i feel like i'd want to
come out like some what do you want
to do it's like some genuine pick
yourself pick yourself oh dude there's
so many
song that you would call it dude i feel
like the motley crue tip drill ti
i'll have to go pretty urban with it ah
man i wanted it it's a little wayne
really oh because you're lollipop little
wayne you're going slow
because that's the thing like those
thunder down under dudes most of them
are gay
they gotta put on an act that they're
seducing women most of those guys are
most those dudes like the way the dick
tastes oh yeah
is that true pretty sure dude how do you
know that to be
that's the rumor i might be off yeah
i'm pretty sure though dude why because
i will tell you
and i'll tell you off air we have a
comedian friend
female we were doing a show together at
a
at a uh resort at a casino
and the show that was playing in the
theater next to us was
some australian strippers and our
comedian friend got down
[Music]
definitely tasted the australian
up down under dick now a bunch of down
under just at one time
just that one we were just there for
that night oh so
she but it was yeah and it's definitely
not gay
he went right up well not not all of
them i'm saying the majority
how it seems like you wouldn't i made
that up it seems like yeah it seems like
you
would want but it's like being a
gynecologist too like i wouldn't want
the job
no i don't i wouldn't want the strip job
either because thunder down under boys
are
jack come on dude that guy in the front
which one which one that's gonna mean
which one again the front how come how
come three of them look like a different
version of ryan seacrest
what the look at the guy on the far left
which guy
okay that looks like my crowd at addison
i was gonna say this looks like your
meet and greet
it really does toss on a couple tap out
shirts and that's a meet and greet for
brendan
which guy do you think out of this
is like oh this dude is the best thunder
down under i'd say they have the long
hair and the tats
i agree i think he doesn't really want
to be there you know but he's [ __ ]
good at it he can do the head shake his
head his long hair is wet
it chose him you know it chose him yeah
yeah i mean
how can you look like that and not find
your way
but how come what a career i can't
believe you did that dude the balls
how do i have better abs in two of those
games more than two
it was i gotta tell you man i here's the
person that i am
i'm not going to tell you i don't like
something if i've never done it that's
fair
and i love making myself uncomfortable
there are a couple things that i'm not
sure uh but they're i like making myself
uncomfortable
i like trying things that are going to
make a good story
i like doing things freaky marriage i
don't know how much you want to get into
that but are you
that freaky with your marriage let's
just say i've pushed the envelope as far
as she wants to go
[Applause]
you know what i mean like a long time
ago i found out where her line is and
that's cool
yeah she's all i guess i'll put on this
arnold schwarzenegger mask
you need me to say i'll be back i can i
mean i don't know if i'm not good with
accents i don't need the accent
no but i like to say come on do it
just one more just say it's not a tumor
just scream get in the chopper and i
will be fine i just can't if you say
it's not a tumor i'm gonna bust
everywhere
i will tell you the weirdest thing that
ever happened to me there was a woman
that um that i
had sex with for a while when i was
single raising the kid sure
and so i could never have sex at my
place because that's where my babysitter
was and i lived in one room you can't
have that
so we had sex in the minivan we used to
have sex i used to find girls who would
have sex in a minivan
not that not that many of them sure but
there was one girl
young and she but her thing was she
liked me to put her
on the baby seat
so she her ass would fit so she wasn't
sitting in it but it was wide enough so
it was lifted
let her lift it over yeah there has to
be some sort of childhood trauma thing i
would assume
she just loved the first echo do you
mind if we have can go upstairs do you
want to have sex in the middle she goes
we get in there she goes will you [ __ ]
me on the car seat and i was like
uh yeah yeah my kid's there but yeah but
the first couple times i remember
bringing a do you have capri sun and
some orange slices
what happened in your childhood that you
need to eat my kids snacks
do you have cheerios in a bag that i can
you put can you put
[Music]
but she loved i in the day the reason i
had to stop was
when there was one night that i forgot
we had sex in the minivan on
on the car seat and i forgot to put the
towel down and so when
my son came down the next day i was like
you know what buddy we're gonna get you
a new seat we're gonna yeah we're gonna
stay out of it we're gonna walk yeah
yeah yeah we're gonna walk
because i had forgotten i was like oh no
no no oh no we can't do that so you draw
the line
i i will tell you dude my the freakiest
group of people i
ever dated were single moms single moms
were they then an outlet like they have
to be so buttoned up all the time
because they have the toughest job in
the world so when they're with you it's
like
the leash is off brendan i had a woman
because i was single at the time too
i had a woman we're both raising kids
and so i got it
and when i walked in this was her rule
she uh she liked to have sex
but she wanted me there at nine o'clock
kid went to sleep at 8 30.
she didn't want me to meet her kid she
didn't want me to see what her place
looked like do you know that when i
walked in
right by the front door there were
blankets and pillows and two bottles of
water
we [ __ ] on the floor i used the
bathroom near the front door
and i got the [ __ ] out good for her and
she was like you don't need to meet my
kids i don't need to know much about you
you don't need to go in my house you
don't need to dance i just want
a physical adult interaction yep
and that was it and she would put two
bottles of water down and i remember
asking her
two i only bring one to the gym what do
you think's happening what do you
think's gonna go down
she's probably thinking she's probably
thinking you
what do you think is happening here but
but single moms were
yeah and you get it you know as a parent
it's like dude i don't have time to
[ __ ] none of that i want to go home
and go to sleep too man i know i got to
get up at six and make lunches
also yeah i get it it was an untapped
and nannies
wow interesting cat have just go back to
street clubs have you ever been to a
male strip club
no i wanted to go last time i was in
vegas because i wanted to take my
grandma and her best friend because
they've never seen like uh dick anything
they've seen dick they've only seen
asian dicks be specific
so i wanted to kind of show them around
those boys from thunder down under
really
they put those dicks in their face man
it gets pretty you know yes for a lap
dance you're getting full
you seem to know a lot about these guys
from thunder down under i'm just asking
you know
yeah i mean you have a lot of facts it's
very strange
but you know what it is you know what my
favorite show was gigolos on showtime
that was such a [ __ ] train wreck that
show can you hear what happened to
homeboy
no though you know like the very like
yogi guy
along here murdered somebody he's in
prison for the rest of his life
unbelievable right jaw dropping when did
that happen like last week
this dude the guy the friendliest one
girlfriend to death in drug-fueled rage
gone for the rest of his life and i'm
sure the boys are gonna have fun with my
god
dude isn't that crazy that was my
favorite show i started watching again
last week that was
a train wreck for sure you know there
was a guy that lived
i used to live in apartment complex
and he was a guy that was on um
star trek voyager and he was a he was a
extra as a klingon
but he had always wanted he had told us
always his dream
to be on star trek so he would wear the
klingon makeup home
and walk around in a robe like taking
out his trash with a klingon you want to
be a klingon you know
he ended up one day we're right in
hollywood where
we hear some banging and some people
screaming i'd stick my head out
he's getting dragged out of his
apartment in his klingon outfit
sure by the cops because he had murdered
a hooker
with a sword yeah yeah and i was like
that checks i knew where this was yeah i
was like that checks
before you even yeah yeah right away guy
wants to dress like a klingon
not 24 7. dude yeah yeah
someone gave him a sword from the set
yeah man that's how his story ends my
brother was like can you believe that
i'm like
yeah yeah the klingon guy dude the cleon
guy yeah what a weird dude if you had
told me that woman
jenny raising the two kids that have
been weird cleon guy yeah i get it
who wears the robe jesus christ let's go
some current events
all right first one
okay so you guys were talking about this
um and
a former employee that worked over in
the nba's uh
program trying to find like the next yao
ming in china
uh it came out yeah
they have a basketball program that's
linked to the nba
and a former employee came out and said
that they're actually physically beating
the players
and it's very similar to almost like a
they described as a world war ii
germany situation where they're
physically beating the players to try to
get them to perform better
it says we were basically working for
the chinese government one former coach
told espn
do they think hitting people makes them
grow
it says one former coach said the
chinese coach fired a ball into a young
player's face at point-blank range then
kicked them in the gut
yeah i mean it goes back and one of the
reasons i did not
uh like i don't have a strong opinion on
the nba in china is i try not to have
strong opinions on things i don't know
enough about yeah because it leaves me
out there
and and rightfully so for someone to be
you don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about
but this type of stuff
if this is true it is such a clear
choice of money
over what's right well they won't but
they won't even address this
like the the commissioner yeah the the
he won't even address it they'll ask him
like no comment
i will say though like [ __ ] at the same
time
i think these people in the government
who are pretending that they care
and they're calling out because i saw us
it's it's some of the stuff is some of
the
up above like what does it say rubio
called
the nba a communist over to the side i
think
oh the wrong side oh yeah yeah was that
it it says something about marco rubio
was saying that the nba is part of
communist china yes
at the same time i don't like
politicians you know rubio doesn't give
a [ __ ] what's happening
do you know what i mean like yeah
again it's complicated but this this one
gets dicey so the adrian
uh they call him housekeeping they call
him woj so
uh senator josh uh holly uh holly yeah
so he wrote an
email and sent to espn and the nba was
like dude you guys want to go on this
black lives matter and all this [ __ ]
what's what about china are you gonna
address that at all and woes is the
number one nba reporter for espn he's so
close to the nba
he responded back [ __ ] you i agree let
me ask you something about this guy
though
without the black lives matter does that
dude
give a [ __ ] about what's happening in
china
that's my point is that like the it's
vilifying
people are just saying like all right if
you're gonna stand on this
mountain how can you not stand for this
mountain i
and i and i i agree with that 100
percent i also agree with like
she's mouth to mouth and i'm just
uncomfortable i'm on board if you need
me to yeah
he'll do it there's a guy from thunder
down under outside
he's got a he's got something for you
quick put on motley crue get him
my thing is this man my only thing is
it's like
i'm with i know what you're saying they
don't really care
because we're not in china yeah it's not
affecting us
and i don't think it's right but i think
the real the reality is
man if you're telling me that
look there are a lot of things in this
country that i that i don't agree with
that i would fight for
that i'm sure are happening in other
countries i'm not willing to fight for
them in other countries
i'm willing to fight for them here right
now but but
but i wonder if they said
hey lebron if if hong kong gets invaded
by
china and they take over your shoe
percentage is going to go down 50 he's
gonna start saying free hong kong yeah
that's that's just where my my issue i
agree i
dude i agree with you and that's why
when you said it's complicated it's so
i agree i hear i'm sure if you talk to
lebron he's like dude i don't want them
to no
not have civil rights but also it's like
what do you want me to do
yes like i i can cry all i want but
i know and also yes
something should be said like so like
when that's the thing about where we're
falling i guess you know what so
if you're the nba don't hide it yeah
don't act like
this and then you know this is going on
and don't bring any attention to it
at least a dress like we don't agree
with it at all yeah all we but we're in
the business of basketball
you know i don't know it's [ __ ]
complicated if one of those guys said
of course i care but i'm gonna clean up
my house first
and then i'm going to get to other
people's houses i'm fine with that that
would make sense and it would be
unhappy and it would be honest yeah
which is
if lebron said the reason why i put
lebron the reason why i put james on the
back of my jersey and not
this other stuff everybody else is doing
is because i realized what's happening
in china and i don't feel comfortable
doing that because
then i'm then i'm just being critical of
a situation
here and not respecting what's going on
over there yeah and plus if you said and
plus you know
those little fellas that make my shoes i
don't want to piss them off too correct
yeah i don't want to get you know an
adidas sign on my
you know he's like so yeah yeah yeah
plus space jam 2 comes out next year
and that's the only place where i'm
gonna sell tickets yeah all right what
do you guys got what else you got
okay so we talked about twitter having
this huge hack the other
week and did you hear the kid who did it
teenager
it's a teenager who hacked into twitter
and they arrest them on
30 accounts against the law it was the
one to do
obama's and all those it was a teenager
who started with minecraft and it led to
other things
but he's the one who hacked twitter
here's my thing so he's young
they arrest them can we not he's young
dude
can we not use that not don't put him
away for the rest of his life
use his intelligence for the good of
america
because right now if we go to war with
china which
probability that happens he's an asset a
hundred percent
he's that smart at this age to hack into
twitter that no one can do
and he's so young you can make him a
[ __ ] ally
i see an opportunity no doubt about
how smart that kid is this dude he grew
up without and you look into him
for the reason i looked into him grew up
a real really rough family life
had no friends in school so he was
picked on
so he started you know he was in this
bitcoin situation where he's embezzling
money all that stuff
but somehow this smart [ __ ]
who's not trained in it yeah taught
himself
to hack into twitter that nobody can do
that's an i look at that go he's so
young
dude he can be flipped let's pay him put
him on the [ __ ]
government payroll and he's an asset we
need him on our team
yeah we as it is the people in our
country are we're getting dumber and
dumber
let's keep the smart ones let's have one
don't send him to prison for the rest of
his life
what you do is he takes a plea deal say
you're going to work for the american
government
and we're not going to put you away
because you're so young if you [ __ ] up
again you're going away
if you help us and we're going to we're
going to pay you're going to get a
payment
this can be your career and just make
sure to jump at that dude just to make
sure everyone knows he's serious too
they should just have a guy
when he's doing his work just have a guy
rest his nuts on his shoulders
all day at work just like yeah rent one
of those guys from thunder
yeah yeah just like oh he's there what
are you making
we got a new job for it you're going to
make sure this kid knows
what's waiting for him yeah just every
30 minutes put your dick on his shoulder
yeah yeah he's gonna know this is the
guy
that's the guy that's the mastermind he
looks kind of crazy he does look a
little bananas
look at that he looks insane yeah
why does he have a crossing guard
[Music]
yeah i don't know was he working at the
front of walmart or i'm really perplexed
by his hair
too like that whole hairline he's scary
i'll get it
he's very scary yeah are you working at
a desk next to that guy
look at him dude he's 17.
you're telling me we can't flip this kid
we have good of america we have to
i think we've been how smart he is at 17
to figure this out i look at his
opportunity dude when i get kicked off
when like when sometimes
i get logged off yeah i freak out i
can't i can't i can't i don't know my
own
password this dude i call this dude
smart yeah this dude's smart i think i
agree
i agree we have him on our team and i
think
also it will be fun have him on our team
but once a month he gets to hack into
somebody's twitter
and we get to see what's going on i
think it'll be fun i think it put it
like we spin a wheel
maybe he hacks the rocks isn't it nuts
dude what about the rock buying the xfl
oh did he is that a cool 15 million
dollars that's it yeah
the whole league that's it yes
well that's this girl who's just as
swole do they now they share steroids
yes that's his ex yeah that's his ex
who's jack city
yes i follow her on instagram for
workout
yes motivation jacked jack dude but
she's bigger than both of us
no i don't know if she's bigger than you
i don't know dude she but those aren't
no jokes your face is pretty scrolled up
she's so jacked
scroll they well they look like brother
and sister let's be real scroll down
yeah uh he says with my trailblazing
partner danny garcia
and redbird capital well he doesn't own
all of it his face is on it uh
we have acquired the xfl with grab tuned
passion i better career on my two hands
with apply these
wow how great is that yeah it's gonna
it's gonna be it's gonna go belly up in
two years but yeah i hear you can i tell
you what i think what rule you ever
watch
xfl horrible he hate me yeah but he hate
me was my favorite
sure do you know what i think would
really help the xfl
good players yes and you know what
separates it from the nfl
i say get rid of hunting
no more punting sure you have to go four
downs unless you're on your own 20 and
closer
you you have to go forward that's weird
about that
statistically jesus christ oh my god i
thought he's having a stroke
me too yeah i'm like yeah left eye
there's only so much
and statistically my brain was like all
right we'll use it
yeah i thought i was fired up did
someone just power him down yeah
you should go for it on fourth down
every time if
the odds but also it makes sense
even as far as coming up with the game
plan it makes more sense go for it on
fourth down
that's what i say i say i say you got to
keep kickoffs because we love them
um if you need to figure out a way so
they're not as dangerous like the xfl
did i didn't mind what if you could only
run
one every four downs because all anybody
likes is passing i love it
but get rid of punting get rid of it
because you know what it does look like
a master play clock
yes and you gotta i like and i like
no white running backs or cornerbacks
yeah kristen mccaffrey come on we're
just spitballing
no white ride receiver but that would
kill the patriots yeah you're right if
you're five eight and white
i'd go slot mach you're a slot machine i
mean callan is the perfect size to be
a slot receiver for the patriots correct
he's and not
that's far off on age yeah wait is he 60
67. yeah yeah yeah somewhere around
there distress he's under 85.
now with those liz jones those lids are
fresh dude he looks like a baby
yeah that you know i hope it does well
the more competition the better but also
again i only really have the bandwidth
for one league
i agree with college of nfl and also if
i'm just watching
second-rate players who couldn't make
the nfl i'm not into it dude you know
what i don't like seeing
i don't like seeing people winded maybe
yo man get in shape [ __ ]
he was like i was working at home depot
i'm not trying to hear that dude
i want to pretend this is your passion
yeah
oh dude you want to see a croc of [ __ ]
the new netflix
uh last chance you you can tell they're
like
we're all out of content someone's like
well what do you gotta go remember that
last chance you season we never aired
because it was
awful and not well put together and we
we
[ __ ] hit it for a reason let's fire
that up
dude it is so poorly done
because have you ever seen last chance
oh yeah it's the best this
is the only scene this one oh you just
came out last night my girls and me and
my girl loved she goes
guess what's out last chance to you i
was like oh my god i
literally did a prayer for netflix i
turned on like what is this [ __ ]
there's no build of character you don't
know any of the players the
the audio's bad what are they gonna do
you know what it's last chance you mixed
with blair witch products
it's like home video it's so bad
but you can tell they're just out of
content and they're like who's on it
uh it's a school uh in northern colorado
or northern california
what are they gonna do for new [ __ ] in
general
well they're firing things back up now
like my boy frank grillo
he i know he's like he has this big
production company they shoot for
netflix
and he i think they're firing up next
week or this week
like atlanta's back filming where they
shoot monster [ __ ]
i think he's shooting costa rica the
problem is the insurance yeah on covet
that's why a lot
like the insurance on copenhagen you
gotta have money to shoot my son
just got a job but they they're
quarantining him for two weeks
in boise all of them are doing that yeah
you have to quarantine for two weeks
uh yeah it is bananas he was your son
was on
spade spade show which got cancelled
which
i thought was the best show on comedy
central the without
you know what's weird when you do those
shows i know spade a little bit
i knew the staff sarah tatiana was a
writer on there yeah tiana was right
around there
there's some other guys who had friends
on there and when you're doing a show
and you get there you know it's cold the
lights are you just like god this set is
cold
but seeing somebody you know you're like
oh you feel so much better
when i see your son i would you know we
know each other so i'm like oh thank god
you know it's just good to see a
familiar face absolutely dude the key to
those shows
and the panel shows in general is just
make sure
at least two of the people on the panel
know each other
a hundred percent just make sure put me
with somebody who i have chemistry with
or that we
didn't know the vibe because when i went
on there and i had
i was with friends we crush it when they
put me on there with two people i have
no idea about
i didn't know the rhythm we don't have
the same they were both
way older than me so i'd make references
to video games and dude
dead air the crowd laughing but it's the
chemistry on set
so on tv there's no crowd right so on tv
they might get it but if the two other
comics don't get it
or spade doesn't get it it's just it's
just it's a nightmare
you were trying to volley in tennis and
they never comes back
you're like [ __ ] you're playing with the
machine yeah you're like [ __ ] you know
what it ends up being
when there's three people who don't know
each other it ends up being
three people telling separate jokes yeah
there's no chemistry you're not riffing
look when you go on say you go on with
theo right
you're gonna make fun of each other yeah
you're gonna be comfortable and it's a
it's a language you both speak and i can
feed off
he'll say a story and i'm like i know
where this is going so i'll throw my bit
in there he'll bounce off my bed i love
also you know what i love
is i love being on panel summit and
semitone a joke and you know and that's
not
how they really think and you're like
that's not right yeah let me tell you a
real story about this yeah yeah yeah
yeah and they're like no no
no no that kind of stuff is what makes
those shows
that's why the show like with with when
spade was super comfortable like when
sandler was on
oh dude watching the i could watch those
two talk
nothing better [ __ ] ever the best
that's a bit yeah i agree with you man
those were
that's what when i was on with those
older comics you just turned to me going
okay boomer
yeah that's all that's was my go-to okay
boomer and they're like what the [ __ ]
dude like i got nothing else
you guys aren't getting any of my
references yeah yeah yeah it's a bummer
man but
that's the the reason those shows and
spade got it right because the guys who
ran spade
tom brunell and brad wallick also ran
chelsea's show
and so they get panel needs camaraderie
it needs it has to be a chemistry it
needs it don't get three randoms
no no no like lesson 101 do or if
they're three randoms they should be
three randoms
who have some things in common correct
like if you did three randoms but it was
three
three guys or have the same interest
maybe or the same sense of humor
yeah you can do it i can piggyback off
of what you're saying and all that stuff
but three completely different people is
bad it just doesn't work
what else you got this here
okay so the other day an inmate two
inmates actually in a oklahoma jail
broke their window
scaled down 12 floors with
bed sheets and one of them managed to
escape for a couple of hours
the other one ended up falling around
the third or fourth floor
and when he uh what do you break his leg
uh
i don't think so it just said that he
was caught and then
quickly arrested after he fell yeah when
you can't walk you get arrested pretty
quickly
yeah wait is that guy is that pablo on
the right
the one these are the uh same guys
just without hair and he looks way
better with a shaved head
i have so many questions yes first of
all
why does he have a window i mean aren't
there any questions plus a window to
where you can get a body out of it yeah
also is it the 1940s
are we is it a cartoon what the
shawshank the [ __ ] is going on what the
[ __ ] that was andy dufresne come up with
this plan
did red give him extra sheets the
[ __ ] are we doing here man what kind of
shenanigan
prison is this what and how many sheets
does this [ __ ] have in his
jail cell that it goes down 12 floors
apparently they were stealing other
soul mates uh sheets tight move and
there
is footage of what it looks like this is
the
the workers trying to figure it out this
is happening oh
[ __ ] that's what i'm saying how did they
get out of there
they said through a window in the report
that's not a that is
dope that's a that's a wall they broke
through a wall that is really cool
okay here's so the one guys well that's
so far
and then they have to jump from there
dude that's that is
farther than 12 floors dude no no where
the
sheet ended that looks like at least 15
feet doesn't it
let me ask you so the one guy is still
on the run uh no he was captured a
couple hours later but
he did manage to uh get away
so he was like out and about for a
couple hours that's high
dude that's two stories up that's 20
feet that's two stories up
no i'm not making that jump i mean i am
once i get down there but why not make
the rope a little longer
just a little bit you went through all
of that
just you one more one more sheet dude
but but but here's another question the
guy who
what are you tying it on to and who goes
first you're like hey
by the one who got [ __ ] up went first
and probably the one that went
first was probably a little out of shape
was like dude i think we need one more
and the guy in shape was like nah
i bet you'll be okay go first and he
fails you got [ __ ]
dude you had to guess you know he was
like no it's long enough no it's not
let's make the window it's long enough
and they threw it down and he was like
[ __ ]
okay we'll still be yeah how bad you
want your freedom
i'm gonna go dude yeah you go first
that's a lot that's a far
jump dude like i was watching look at
those are people at the bottom
oh dude you're really [ __ ] with
things oh no like your ankles especially
in the prison shoes
those prison uggs with no comfort no the
flat bottom
prisoners make chuck taylor's awesome
shoes soft
those are not good you're talking about
the piece of wood with
[ __ ] prison nugs present you want to
go prison up no you can't be jumping two
floors
prison hugs that right there i am dude
you want some [ __ ]
i was watching on uh shark week i think
it debuts this week but they had old
[ __ ]
guys escaping from alcatraz that was
some [ __ ]
told you was like how bad you want your
freedom i guess man and what the
warden would tell him goes there this
place is surrounded by great whites
when we've seen it if you leave you're
gonna get eaten
and these guys are still like [ __ ] it
yeah and did it and they all died yeah
and i think
there was a group where they don't know
what's happening someone got away
they go gain ice cold water currents
like crazy if you go out by that day and
the warden's giving you fear porn every
day like
johnny tried to escape and we watched a
great white eat them and you're like
holy
[ __ ] they're lying out sharks you're not
that's to swim that is near impossible
they they have a competition now where
people actually swim there and back
even with great whites in the water they
don't give a [ __ ] my uncle pax used to
do it every year
he'd swim around it and back why i know
it crazy do you know
when i was doing that shark week show
one of the guys asked me
he said you scared sharks oh yeah i go
that's and this was back before i knew
is anybody not scared of him
these guys are not scared of shark well
they like him
this guy told me if a shark swims at you
swim right at it that that
so well that's like the the bear scout
leader
where they're like hey if you see a bear
make a loud noise and
scare them away you know what happened
to that guy yeah well all the
scouts watched their leader get eaten
ass first
no yeah the bear went what are you doing
dude turn around
yeah ass first no yeah he got eaten
alive in front of all the boy scouts
you know boy scouts escaped you know the
bear was like
i'm gonna make a point here so i'm gonna
eat a mess first yeah he's like listen
whoever told you to do this cautionary
tale this isn't kids run away i don't
know what
safety plan whoever told you this
probably bring bear spray let me show
you what happens when you yell at me i
know kids think eating ass is cool now
[Applause]
let me go ahead and show you guys let me
show you how bear does it
yeah no this is not by the way yeah i
love that
punch of bear in the nut or punch a
shark in the nose i swam with sharks and
the guy told me
dude and i don't have enough time to
tell you the story but i didn't
we went out to swim with sharks and they
put me in a wetsuit
with a snorkel and the guy shot black
dips i was out uh makos
okay a little dangerous yeah and uh
they're like the meth heads of sharks
yeah they're
but also nurse sharks all right but the
guy says to me he goes um
can you uh we're on camera this is for
discovery
and he goes so tell me um when's the
last time you you snorkeled
and i go i've never snorkeled and he
goes stop the cameras and he goes you've
never snorkeled
and i said no and he goes bring out the
second waiver
yes and i said your life away i said
what's the second waiver and he goes you
know what the second waiver is
and he said to discovery as he's having
me sign it he goes i can't throw him in
the water
much less with sharks he said how good
are you a swimmer i go i don't know how
to
swim
he was like he's like how the [ __ ] do
you get this gig
like she's really funny in good light
yeah dude but he i couldn't they
when they pushed you know what i didn't
know i didn't know that
with with the scuba gear with i mean the
wetsuit they tie a weight a weight
around you
so you're not as buoyant i sank it's
such a good thing they had me tied to a
rope did they just come in the water
did they chum the water around me dude
it was but for the manuel it that clip
is up
too all the shark week clips around i
was scared out of my mind
also it's one of callan's jokes on an
old special
so i can say it to his point you ever
tried punching
underwater yeah this is the cow's joke
yes so when a great white comes up
and you're like [ __ ] get out of here
the great white's like
again the same thing that the bears can
do dude i'm gonna eat your ass first
just to make a point we're gonna make an
example out of you
i've always said man the only way i'm
not getting eaten by a shark is if that
shark doesn't like the taste of [ __ ]
because
that's just [ __ ] i told everybody i go
my new nickname when you throw me in the
water
is brown cloud that's fair because i'm
out that's a squid movie yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah that's what squids do not with [ __ ]
but they do a dive
yeah but all you have is [ __ ] i'm not
anti you're all out of dye
what's your move if a shark comes up i
you know i've watched that movie dark
blue or d blue blue yeah where he like
hit this sword where he grabbed like the
shark goes to bite and he like hangs on
yeah
so probably that yeah super realistic oh
dude
you're [ __ ] have you ever tried like
moving out
again in water it's like you're pushing
do you like when i was in hawaii there
was a
sea turtle i'm like oh i'm gonna grab
onto them like uh nemo
i'm gonna grab on the sea turtle a live
one yeah and cruise on them
dude as the sea turtle's like from me to
cat i'm like i'm gonna swim towards him
he was so gone it was like
i mean yeah yeah yeah and i'm like this
a shark no what am i gonna do i'm gonna
do this
do you know there is there are people
and you can see the video online who put
have you seen them put sharks to sleep
yeah crazy and they came up and they
stand them up yeah
well david blaine ate uh a banana
underwater with great whites around him
a banana why a banana just to make it
more difficult i don't know
he ate a banana under in the o i think
he's in the ocean with great whites i
wonder why a banana
i just to show how gangster he is i mean
that
look at
he looks identical to my brother jay yep
and that's whatever
but uh whoa what's happening there
um yeah yeah but he went underwater
great whites and ate a banana i'm i
have no desire even shark week was like
i think we're gonna pass on yeah we're
like
that was like a special for him there
are there are
some people who get way closer to the
sharks than i would
paul de gelder being one of them but
like
i i mean i i just don't know that i have
the temperament i'm
i'm too i know people say though you
don't have to be scared i'm too scared
okay i also don't like the people
they're they're playing underwater
eating bananas smoking cigarettes they
make sense
but uh the other thing is people are
like oh with sharks they don't like the
taste of humans they confuse with a seal
oh really what shark told you that
that's
[ __ ] dude no they're just like i'm
gonna [ __ ]
there's something moving i'm hungry i'm
gonna eat that [ __ ] thing and by the
way like don't worry they don't like the
taste of us
oh yeah how'd you figure that out and by
the way
the i don't if it it doesn't matter if
he likes taste or not if he's still
biting me
i'm still getting [ __ ] bit by a shark
also i'm not buying it
dude yeah whether he has buyer's remorse
or not doesn't
it doesn't matter to me i prefer not to
get
but watching together talking to
gelderman you talk to him about getting
bit by that shark
the paul the guy who was uh the
australian yeah
and you had him in here arm and leg yeah
right yeah
when you talk to him you know what i saw
him at the mall and i was with my family
and i panicked
my son was like what's wrong with his
leg i'm like let's get the [ __ ] out
because i don't want to be tara reid do
this let's get the [ __ ] out of here
you know one of his favorite jokes to do
with that hand is he can
literally crush your crush your hand
that's like robotic hand right he's like
robocop he can crush your hand
and i found that out because when i
first met him i was like hey man because
i'm a comic you can't come to me with a
fake arm and leg and
you're not getting and be bald and good
looking and i'm like were you a bond
villain
like do you have one that shoots fire
yeah and he goes next suicide squad yeah
he goes watch this one and he goes put
your hand in there
and he started to squeeze it hard and he
was like you still think that's funny
i'm like no no
because you can feel your bones yeah i'm
embarrassed i saw him we're at the
i think we're at the grove or the
century city mall my kid was like what's
wrong with his leg and i panicked and we
ran off you were like we're going to run
because
dude he's a super good dude stud i felt
bad
hey he's been on the show i think yeah a
while ago right for shark week yeah he's
great
is he in la he's in la man yoshi i'm
back on for shark week
you and i should have him i would love
to he's one of my favorite people let's
have my
next week or the following week i
absolutely look at my schedule
why don't you yeah yeah yeah i got a lot
of that too let me check with callum
yep he says you're good what else yeah
yeah
yeah yeah i would definitely that would
be fun you need to be in town
yeah that would be great all right i'll
apologize to him for running off at the
mall
it's not the first time yeah i get
scared so you guys know what cameo is
right
yes yes okay so this woman is
alexa bliss from wwe she is on cameo and
a man paid 431 dollars
asking her out on a date and this was
her response shoot your shot son hi
antonio first i just wanted to say thank
you so much for your message that was so
sweet thanks for the money is what she
means um i'm
extremely flattered uh with your request
but unfortunately i am seeing someone
um but i know that there's someone out
there for you
i know it's a little hard right now with
everything going on with kobe and having
to stay inside so i hope you are staying
inside staying healthy and happy
but i know once everything clears up you
got to get out there you know just get
out there meet someone and
someone will show you what it means to
be loved oh wow show you that you
deserve all the happiness in the world
and be treated the best way
jesus know that someone's out there what
a great way to get turned down
just like dory says just keep swimming
that's a car
wow what a nice lady yeah
but also you paid 400 he's all ha [ __ ]
she just saying dory yeah i paid her 400
dollars to jerk off the door
jerking off to this and you shout it out
which is ellen i'm [ __ ]
lady i don't man like we all like it
he's probably like
[ __ ] man i do appreciate him
shooting his shop for 400 yeah but like
how did he come up with 431
what's the is that i think that was uh
the amount through her cameo i don't
know why it's that exact
but on the report i read it was like 4
30 and
is it isn't caitlyn jenner's like 10
grand to ask her a question
something like that it's a no one it's a
ridiculous question
when i don't want from somebody that i'm
going to masturbate to
is a sincere response no that he would
dude he wants to jack off to her going
[ __ ] you
yeah and he's like yeah just give me
call me a dirty scumbag but don't be
like you'll find love
i'm not looking i'm not why i'm paying
me for you know where i'm at in life
you're paying 400
to ask you out i'm not looking for a
nice response no no no that was the best
response ever
show me half a nipple show me a show
question she's
expensive shout out quarter of an areola
that's what he gets
she gets she gets but i don't think
anybody
the most expensive shout out if you were
gonna do one
a cameo no no say you had to you were
gonna go okay
there's one person that i want to get a
cameo from a shout out oh good question
who would yours be am i single
you're saying what world are we living
in you're living in your world right now
but you are
single halsey that was quick i didn't
know
so i didn't even finish i don't know i
didn't even finish the rest of it
i had some other things but i didn't
that's too quick yeah i don't need to
say anything
it doesn't matter i was setting the
table and i ate i ate the appetizer by
the way i
i just barely put the placemat and i was
ready to file it
i was ready yeah halsey really yeah
right off the bat she's single i'm
single
you know yeah what is it about her i
don't know she's so talented
what about like a billy not like a billy
eilish too young
yeah how old is halsey
20 something isn't true she's my age 20.
i should go to be 20 something right
billions uh billy i listen just from 18.
oh i don't i don't that's how
18 is still legal out of the thing i am
oh me i
i don't know i thought maybe she was 21
22. but do you ever talk to a 21 year
old
not anymore like no but it's like i
don't even at 36 37 with the [ __ ]
stuff halsey's 25 but it's like a rough
25
she's lived but i'm officially so for me
dude no it's just
trauma if i was single my line would be
nobody younger or
the same age as my kids yeah yeah i mean
i got it so my oldest son is 27
so i could not and plus to me we have
nothing common
nothing like these guys you find out
dating like 50 year olds marrying 20
5 year olds like what do you guys talk
about oh you ever ask your opinions on
hong kong how's that going is she gonna
ask me to do a tick tock
yeah i know what wait you didn't you
didn't answer who would you who would
who's your candidate you're let's say
you're single you're you're joshua if
your age right now
shoot or shoot you can do it you're
going to attempt spanish in it
listen yeah i know she's married to a
billionaire yes but i'm gonna
yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna maybe get that
you know who i might care oh
tell me she is still not dude
i'm going to go on record bomb the best
looking woman ever on film dude
dust until dawn jackson city
i wish i was that python all day and
night
bet you i don't care who else you put on
there dust till dawn
selma hayek winner i'd even throw
desperado selma hayek in there
yes but dude look at her but her
that to me is it doesn't on film do you
type in
dust dust i'm so glad you said that
because there's no it's a
no dude
[Music]
[Applause]
look at the snake this is before britney
spears did all that
[ __ ] oh and dude i went mine a cameo
with britney spears crazy ass right now
dude but that could get thick
but oh perfect oh dude that's a great
call out yeah to me it's
just way better no it's a no-brainer no
no look i'm an old person yeah i know
it makes sense though i'm an old person
you know and so dude i wouldn't mind
doing it can't do
she's ridiculous i who you dude it makes
you forget how ugly quentin tarantino is
that's how high she is you don't you
forget he's even in the movie he might
be you forget that george clooney has a
neck tattoo she's so hot
that's one of my favorite movies he does
one of my favorite movies i grew up on
it
uh uh he's a neck tattoo and he's a
badass there he is there's
that's him being a badass down there
yeah but the guy that dude who had the
guns come out of his
one of my favorites but tarantino in
that movie
he's exceptionally ugly oh dude he's
still you're like oh he's really ugly
it's distractingly ugly yeah he's
exceptionally he's great in pulp fiction
pulp fiction what was he impulse fiction
well he directed it but then he's also
they come to him after
they blow out marvin's brains and they
give him the santa cruz
that's right that's right you look like
dorks that's right
that's where him and the wolf start
laughing at him because yeah that's what
you look like
dude yeah there he is he's adorable so
creepy
industrial dot he was so when he kills
the the
maid to me like there was a spoiler
you don't get i when that's when i was
like oh this is
as real to tarantino like he's my
favorite director
he's my favorite director dust till dawn
all the movies done pulp fiction right
uh kill bills dude once upon a time in
hollywood's my
all-time number one favorite movie can i
tell you
i had to watch it twice to like it three
times for me
because and i love it now i'm gonna tell
you something
that just dawned on me from watching the
movie the fourth time
and when i was like oh this movie is
genius because from the
the reason i didn't like it the first
time is because i i did you go with
preconceived notions that was gonna be
about charles manson i went in
preconceived notions by what the
trailer was yeah i'm like oh this is
gonna be a fast paced
and it was a slice of life movie and you
know the thing about margot robbie that
people hated the most that she didn't
talk
do you know what i loved about that she
didn't talk
you know what he did in my mind this is
what he did in my mind with her playing
sharon tate
with him with and and with her not
talking he
basically in my mind he was like
i want you to watch she doesn't need i
want you to watch this person
living their life and think you could be
living your life
and just living your life we're gonna
we're gonna be for her we're gonna be a
voyeur yes and we're going to watch her
live her life
because you're all expecting me to kill
her you're all expecting
her to get murdered by her group and now
what i'm going to show you is
look how easy that it could have been
this person stepped in this way
if she went right instead of left i
agree so so from the best geniuses
i agree the best scene in cinematic
[ __ ] history
is when margie margot robbie is playing
sharon tate and she goes to the movie
theater
and they're showing the actual footage
from sharon tate in the movie
but margot robbie's playing sharon tate
she's in the movie they're looking
around everyone's clapping oh
dude because if you know about sharon
tate yeah that's the murders which on
balls deep in it did i go to the murder
house yeah i did
the thing is it's so [ __ ] good dude
yeah when she
she has her feet up she and you know she
takes her sandals off she's like this
looking around showing the actual foot
of sharon tate
you might have to pump your brakes on
the best scene in the history it's my
favorite dude
but but dude it's my face super good how
about when leonardo dicaprio is [ __ ]
up his lines
and you know this was all this was he
just this wasn't written
you mean in the trailer my wife's
favorite scene from that movie
the best thing when he goes in he's like
[ __ ] stupid and he's like
i swear to god i'm gonna [ __ ] blow
your head off you [ __ ] these lines up
i'm gonna blow your head off
that was you know that was none of that
was written is that right none of it was
written during balls deep in this none
of it was written
that he goes oh oh he goes roll the
cameras they're like what the [ __ ] he
doing he did
all that just improv he he's a genius
yes and i will tell you look man
if you're going to show me a movie with
brad pitt taking his shirt off i'm
probably going to go
100 dude when how about i've
i want to be him yeah when he's in that
old school car he's in the cool shirt
and the the leather thick and he's
driving to the [ __ ] saddle ranch
oh my god do you want to picks up the
girl that was and isn't that
what's her name roberts is that julie
roberts's niece i think right
emma roberts emma roberts it was a it
wouldn't kick around my car it was in a
it was a every scene
was amazing my problem when i first saw
it was i didn't feel like
that's who i want to be how could you
not want to be that guy
i grew my hair out because this did you
really yeah i cut it during quarantine
but i grew my hair up because of that
movie
i will tell you brad pitt is like
everybody has their from north star he's
your north star
for me legends of the fall brad pitt
because you get a little bit of everyone
sure
you get army brad pitt clean shave and
you get native american brad pitt fight
club too much
dedication just one straight brad pitt
yeah but you get three brad pitts
you get that brad pitt you get that brad
pitt
you get that bread come on man
you get a lot of different you get that
brad pitt
that's who getting this oh [ __ ]
branches of life yeah
dude i didn't mind an interview with the
vampire brad pitt yes
you get all you get brad pitt a lot of
brad pitts for one bread you know what
and there's never enough brad pitt
come on man and once he won the oscar
but leonardo should have [ __ ] won it
too man he was so good
god he was so good dude you're going to
give leonardo dicaprio the oscar for
[ __ ] the reverend he doesn't say a
word he got [ __ ]
dude that bear eat a mask first try d
mask first
think about it he did it
god that movie is good too but once punt
pond
brad pitt the long
fall dude look at that brad pitt yeah
come on man i mean cat he's good looking
yeah
he unbelievable i think is the one of
the most beautiful people
and you find out he's a raging alcoholic
oh he
he's one of us yes and i always knew or
thought he was for sure a weed smoker
like oh yeah yeah oh and then he's also
a podcast fan he listened to mark maron
do you ever hear mark martin interview
him and leonardo dicaprio
what they did like uh a thing they were
doing a media thing and they sat down
with mark maron
and brad pitt's like first of all i'm a
huge fan and he starts going through all
his episodes you're like
can you listen to the podcast
they made the interview so much better
because then leonardo was like oh brad
pitt co-signs on marc maron
and then it was just this trio and there
was like
synergy and you're like oh [ __ ] would
you fan girl if brad pitt sat down and
did your podcast
it's hard to get me to fangirl but i'm
such a fan of his yeah probably
who would you fan girl moreover uh
tarantino or him
oof him i think so too how he is
so you think he's just genetically
gifted
or is it you mean i i mean he's like why
is he so shredded all the time
i can only tell you his how old is he
he's probably my age
i can only tell you that i feel like
we're probably around the same size
but you guys and you guys have similar
genetics because you're bodied up
similar
well he's older than it's like he's 56
dude you're old
i'm 50. but like for me
you know as long as i keep my body
around a certain weight
i can stay shredded-ish and you're not
like on a hardcore diet
either right i'm just dude brad pitt and
glorious bastards
that's a top five film the jew bear
they're spock is the jew bear there oh
no spock
that's that's right and he's a gay man
yes
zachary quint quinto the this dude i
grew up my master is this one of your
favorite
tarantino films bastards dude top three
what about pawn time in hollywood which
you know the one thing about that it was
written little play django was crazy
good
dude leonardo dicaprio django next level
to me that might be oh he was so he's so
oh my god he's so good you know what the
one thing i would love to see him do
fury it's not a quentin tarantino but
fury i
cut my hair like that you like you
change your hairstyle up by your movies
huh yeah
i go pretty i'm pretty straight doc from
back to the future with my hair
yeah so that pretty stays pretty much
the same but like this this
movie for me wasn't one of my favorite
characters
was it wasn't but was as a jewish man
that's not one of your favorite movies
not one of my favorites jewish but i
wish i was after that
i will tell you that i think it's a
great movie
but he's done so many tarantinos
ambassadors if it's on it's one of the
movies i watch it's
so good paul fiction i'll watch all day
every time what else
i'll watch every uh he wrote it he
didn't direct it but true romance
sure classic true romance see where i
put that in my top five
movies ever fair just look at all of the
people
in is my boy michael rapport in that
yeah dude rappaport's in that
gary oldman's in that the scene between
christopher walken
and dennis hopper in that movie might be
my favorite
movie dude what about walking in
glorious bastards
christopher walking in he's not in it
yeah
you know what that is he's in force gump
and he hides the watch up his ass
yes not a quinn that's pulp fiction yeah
forget about that that's
that's right with bruce willis yeah yeah
you're right you're right yeah that's
what that's like
you threw it you threw it yeah yeah yeah
my brain is like yours i'm like
nicotine it's not the end-all be-all you
know we're still
ct still alive
you want to take a break and go more
nicotine i'm like why
yeah you should call me rap you call me
ralph
and you think you directed door to
explorer yeah
yeah i'm with you dude what else you
guys got
let's go to this how cool is this
a guy promised his friend back like in
1992 if he ever won the lotto he would
split the you know the mornings with him
right they both they were
still friends no i think they kind of
moved on oh wow yeah so he reconnected
with him and kept the promise
i'll be like roger like who the [ __ ] is
kevin remember he's like dude how you
doing
i'm good i won the lottery remember that
handshake
22 mil what a dumb [ __ ] hey listen yeah
that's fair
if i called you 22 years later and said
brandon listen remember that thing we
didn't really like yeah i'm like i'm
gonna give you a hundred thousand
dollars you'd be like holy [ __ ]
11 million you got to give him if i said
i'm gonna give you ten thousand you'd be
like
yeah like dude what's the catch what do
you need yeah we got ten thousand i
would have been happy
but look at how which who's the dummy
which one do you think i'm not sure
which one's which
yeah the blue shirt me too
because the guy with the other with the
mustache is smiling like i can't believe
it
yeah wow i am 22 million
blown away i don't know if they were
like homies continually but
it seems like they were here that's cool
called his friend so yeah i'm not
30 years later that's crazy no way hold
on he so he called him he goes he called
me and i said
are you are you jerking my bobber
so that's kind of older tell you exactly
from missouri
that's there yeah you can i tell you
wisconsin
the dude in the blue shirt does look
like he's jerk the bobber yeah yeah
yeah not this time man just giving you
half
of my 22 million no more jerking buddy
look what it comes out to not anymore
i'm rich [ __ ]
after everything it's 5.7 million each
each taking home 5.7 after
taxes so i imagine how much this guy is
giving like just to do this to keep his
promise
so you get 22 million so after taxes
you're messing with 11 million
and then you're getting half of your 11
million i bet you he didn't realize that
i bet he thought he was getting 11. and
then like yeah very cool so taxes
wouldn't take half of it yeah because
it's a prize so you're getting half of
that
he's like but i already called the
bobber like yeah we know dude you gotta
give him half
he's like wow he's like but i'm already
giving away i bought a house for five
mil
i only have seven hundred thousand left
like i know well we didn't say give it
away
yeah enjoy your house yeah enjoy the
house it's all you have now if you had
11 million
it's 11.4 right no 11.2
no i'm giving away
i'll give them the point too is it point
it's seven point four
no it's ten no i don't know five percent
can't do math
total five point seven times two is
eleven point each got five
five point seven that's eleven point
four eleven point four so i'm giving
i'm a listen i'm giving a hundred to him
i'm giving a hundred
a couple other i'll probably give him a
mill a poem like can we hear that
handshake
we won a mill is a good chunk too giving
him a milf for
what he would have never known do you
think you would know
do you think he would have called you
and been like hey man remember 22 years
ago
we were dumb and we were broke and you
promised me half
i'd have been like no i don't know i
don't remember who was that dude
what's your name yeah bobber dude this
bobber
yeah that was in the past dude i was
drunk
off mountain dew yeah we was that when
we were
making moonshine yeah what are you
talking about yeah we're going to be
friends forever
dude 30 years later a promise through a
handshake
wow that's awesome i i i
respect it i guess yeah but you trust
them that's pretty dope like you did
yeah
accountant yeah numbers yes you got
and they're pretty old you got the ellen
thing so okay so james corden
have you ever worked with ellen no i've
heard some terrible
everyone in the business says that yeah
it's starting to come out right yeah
have you seen what's going on
i haven't seen you should be canceled
but
either do i you know who you should ask
you're really canceling her
so sh they're thinking that she might
actually leave the show now
so in case she does leave uh james
corden is one of their top
picks for replacing her which is weird
because it's the ellen show i love him
though he's awesome yeah
everyone loves him can't miss here's
what i would ask before they
and i think she's going to quit too
because i don't think she's going to be
one want to be under the scrutiny of her
and jimmy kimmel done
i don't think kimmel's done do you think
so
voluntary or i think they came down like
hey there's too much [ __ ] here we don't
want to deal with it
you can take a break and walk away
otherwise you're going to force our
hands
he was on a show called the man show in
the 90s i know what do you think
but nbc or abc whoever the [ __ ] he's
with didn't
expect this cancer culture to come out
they weren't expecting this and they
don't want to deal with the
repercussions
i think online is everything before
they canceled her they should have sat
down with the people who need the jobs
who were working there and said listen
yeah that's the big one
listen the staff yeah listen but they
say the staff is the one who but they
should have asked listen
we know she's rough we can have a talk
with her
privately and say we're gonna this is
gonna be the end we need to
but do you guys want to lose your jobs
right now do you want her to walk away
because she watched it all you are
leaving i'm assuming a bunch of i'm just
going to bring in his people he's going
to
have
james what he does he's very good at but
he wants his people i would assume
so i would at least because i feel bad
for the staff members
if it's between having a job for an
[ __ ]
or not having a job especially right now
i know i gotta
you know what's weird well not weird but
you know it came out and somebody was
gonna take the blow four
they came from her producer they're like
you know it was the producers they
created this toxic environment
and then somebody came out the guy from
uh all about raymond the you know the
ray romano no the other one the tall
comic yeah he came out romano's comic
too
uh but the other guy came out and he
goes it starts from the top
if you're acting like that he's acting
like that's true
yeah and i was like yeah he's kind of
right that is 100 100 true because
if i have a show and i find out the
producer being a dick he's out
without a doubt 100 he's doing what the
leaders tell him to do
i just birds flock together i would i
would ask
i would i feel bad for those people and
you know should she lose her job well
no but see if if you know the racism and
they tell me like the bullying that
makes sense i agree but should she lose
her job for being an a type personality
[ __ ]
because she's good on tv how many
regular workplaces are there bosses who
are [ __ ]
steve was steve jobs the nicest guy i
read
his book me too and i'm not gonna lie to
you
i at one point during the book i was so
you don't like him at one point during
the book terrible i was so disgusted
with who he was
i was like where's the chapter on cancer
yeah when does when does the [ __ ] i'm
just gonna
chapter 12 where you get yeah i know
he's terrible let's see if he becomes a
better person creative mastermind
terrible father
you know denied you know the child for a
long time piece of [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
brilliant though so but why but but but
why do people
walking around and i'm not excusing
ellen or saying she should keep her job
she's good at it are we gonna now fire
every boss who's an [ __ ] across the
united states
agree is that what happens now because i
tell
you know what i always told my kids if
you have an [ __ ] boss or teacher
yeah that's gonna happen sometimes a
hundred percent figure it out yeah
you still i had my son had a teacher he
was like she yells
all the time she's kind of abusive i'm
like all right figure it out
if she hits you if she hits you or
something come to me yeah but if she's
making you uncomfortable
or this is not going to be yeah it's
happening
they say you're such an [ __ ] and like
the producers followed suit like it's
just a toxic environment i don't know
enough about
me neither i don't i've never dealt with
her personally but every
person i know in the business it's just
and i don't form an opinion until i deal
with it one-on-one myself i don't know
i've never experienced her but
everyone goes dude she's the worst i'm
like no she's the nice girl there's all
these
games and nope but does james corden
need another job
come on man everybody's hurting though
this dude needs another job i like him
pool karaoke but you know i was on a um
i did a show for tbs recently the
tournament of laughs
and it was like where we all recorded
funny bits and we they put us up
like a ncaa tournament against each
other and did you go against
uh first week i went in against somebody
i didn't honestly i don't know
in the second week i went against
gilbert gottfried and lost but i
stuff yeah gilbert i also wasn't out
there sure
pimping it the way i should have but i
they were like i was like who's hosting
it
oh piff the magic dragon beat
chip jefferson chip jefferson is jim
norton jim norton
oh it's jim norton it's jim norton's
character oh wow
but my thing is like yeah they gave the
job the hosting job to jason sudeikis
i'm like nice to see a [ __ ]
up-and-comer getting a gig oh i know
this dude he needs a gig i know what
what it is amazing
he was bored and bud light went to him
yeah dude you need a famous person to
host this
million dollars i have nothing to do
yeah let's i'm at home i can host it
from my house which is what he did yep
is that it that's pretty much it all
right
you want some more no good those are
good man
did we go long this is the longest i
think we've done it in probably
close to three hours a couple of years
i'm sorry dude
i apologize i talked your hair off no
i'm good yeah oh you just
touched on male dancing and i went
yeah man i i hope i didn't take up too
much you know i love you man
yeah i think you me and the shark guy i
will text him
right when we're done let's set that up
get me the time because he lives out
here yeah
[ __ ] yeah shark week's next week yeah
and he would
i bet you might be going on this week
but either way we could do it wednesday
friday
is that what plaque which one was black
is that that's what youtube gave to you
when you got a hundred thousand now they
give it to you when you get a million
yeah i got one of those you got a
million yeah yeah we're close not
homeboy available actually this week
he'll probably be packed with shark week
stuff next week is probably perfect
that could be good awesome all right all
right deal we love you man thanks for
answering the bad call
thanks for having me i really appreciate
it this is the fighter and the wolf
we're out